[Music]
going crazy man
welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i am mark bernard
[Applause]
um all right kids we are trying for you
at home
uh on the internet we're trying a very
first here
uh we're doing uh fat man beyond with
mark at his house and normally i'm
i'm at my house and and you know jc
banff man
she's straight streams he's got is he
doing that behind my back is that going
to happen the whole [ __ ] night
yeah now that i see it [ __ ] it yeah take
it off
we're streaming the show together uh the
only difference
is um instead of me being home i'm at
smod castle
last night was the grand opening of our
little podcast theater
in leonardo new jersey in the same
building as quick stop the convenience
store that started all the cradle
of civilization as we call it around
here and stuff so
i'm here at smog castle with a full
house is there a way to show off the
audience josh or no
that was the longest all right so
there's
that's terrible [ __ ] that camera lose
that nobody wants to look at my ass
from your camera just turn it like yeah
rack out and show the backs of the heads
and [ __ ] like that
and that's how i make movies i'm like do
this and something will happen
let's uh let's turn on the house lights
real quick just so people can see these
people are real
yeah castle keeper ernie o'donnell
is racing to the back to turn on the
house light so you can see that these
people are real
look at all those people
look at them look at them they're all
shot with the video quality of a morton
downey jr
episode ladies and gentlemen um
so this is us getting to do fat man
beyond with like an audience normally we
do it at scum and villainy cantina with
live people and me and marker in the
same room
but tonight i'm here we got an audience
mark
has this audience here plus the audience
of the internet but has
no audience in in the room that he's
at where are your [ __ ] 50 people mark
i told you to bring
50 people with you i
uh i they they could not pay the toll so
i left them behind
um what have you been up to my good
friend i haven't seen you in
oh days since i left
uh i'm good man i'm good i uh the last
time i saw you was at a
party um to celebrate the upcoming
premiere
of one masters of the universe
revelations that's absolutely right
yes christian
christian jack up mark much much higher
would you
yeah can you not hear me am i not
booming through like the uh all father i
hoped i would be
you're sounding like odin himself um
now that sounds much better um what's
going on my friend
um it's been a it's been a busy work
week i had um
i had a pitch meeting on friday what is
today saturday so that would be
yesterday
right um for a for a fancy movie project
at a fancy movie studio
um i don't know how it went other than i
got a lot of atta boys
in the in the room it's like great pitch
that was really good
nice work pal um that could all mean
diddly dip [ __ ] but i will take it
as the warm bath that i needed it to be
um so the week was prepping for that
so and and knowing what that was which
obviously won't share and stuff
some heavy duty prep went into it i
would assume there was there was some
there was some deep prep
you know and also because i'm a
procrastinator
it was a lot of deep prep that i did in
like four days
that i probably could have done in like
three months but that's not how my brain
works
um you've been practicing a lifetime for
this though so
i think you were ready and ready for the
moment to say the least
i was ready to go mark is already
talking about
coming out and joining us here in the
real world at smod castle
probably the second half of august that
right yeah like a
second or third third or fourth weekend
of august i think so we'll be able to do
this with mark
uh sitting right next to me uh when that
happens but until then
your week you've been getting ready for
the pitch thing uh
my week was getting ready for uh this
smod castle
grand opening which happened last night
uh we did vegan abattoir the show that i
do with harley
we did jane style and bob get old and uh
both of those shows were sold out as you
can see from the video it's a small
theater black box 50 seats and stuff
like
that but let's be honest the people here
absolutely overpaid to see the [ __ ]
show so
i was so delighted anybody [ __ ] came
so we had two sold out shows and then
the third show was me
showing this smodcast cartoon movie that
steve stark made years ago that
we've never put out but like you know
and i financed it and [ __ ] but like
i didn't care because i love the movie
so much i watch it i smoke weed and
watch it all the time so i've been
watching this movie by myself in my
office
for like six years and last night was
the first time i got to watch it
with an audience and it was the you know
late show and it didn't
sell out so for most of the week it
looked like only
six [ __ ] people were gonna be here
like when we had the things at which
point i was going to be like
let's just go out to eat you know like
[ __ ] it's the beauty of the thing
when you own the theater like let's
cancel the show and go to my house and
smoke weed instead
like all six people have been like [ __ ]
yes
um so when i got there we wound up being
like two-thirds full and [ __ ] it was
like 30 people
35 people or something so it was really
nice and i got to watch it
with a [ __ ] audience man and hear
people
laughing at [ __ ] that i have been
laughing at for like [ __ ] years by
myself
with confirmation though i'm like oh my
[ __ ] i wasn't crazy man like that was
fun
but it was an absolute [ __ ] delight
we had a smod castle
in um california years and years ago
on santa monica boulevard matty cohen
and i opened it ten years ago it just
came to a close ten-year anniversary and
stuff
um and i never thought we'd get to do it
again here we are
getting to do it again man so uh we're
in new jersey you can find us
uh obviously don't come tonight we're
sold out [ __ ] off but um
it's like that [ __ ] bible story
there's no room at the end not tonight
mary and joseph would come the next
night they get a room but that night no
[ __ ] room and [ __ ] same thing here
come down to smod castle uh ladies and
gentlemen see a show we got some shows
tomorrow and whatnot
um i want to thank the folks that made
this possible uh ernie o'donnell
built this [ __ ] place and for the
people in the room does it look great or
[Applause]
what
ernie and rajiv are my partners and
stuff and then we got good folks who
gave us lots of free [ __ ] who i want to
quickly shout out
tvs behind me upon which you're watching
mark bernard
looming over me like big brother and
[ __ ] uh those come from the good folks
at tcl
uh who run the tcl theaters uh who put
my footprints in cement man so they gave
us some free tvs
we thanked them for that very very nice
uh the folks at zoom who do our mixing
board that's the only reason you can
hear me and while the people out there
can hear us and stuff
uh and the good folks at sure
microphones uh i'm holding right in my
[ __ ] face
if you want something dick like in your
face that's powerful sure microphones
um we thank them uh for their uh
generous uh gifts uh to smok castle for
the folks at home who are like
where is this we're in new jersey at the
quick stop building where i made clerks
like nearly 30 years ago
so quick stop is at the other end of
this building this is the end of the
building we rarely ever showed in the
movie if never i don't think we've ever
shown it
in the movies once and stuff so when we
were about to go on the jay and samba
reboot roadshow tour uh we came to
jersey and i kind of fell in love with
the idea with ernie and rajiv about like
let's open a [ __ ] theater let's open
smod castle again
right here in the [ __ ] quick stuff
powerful ley lines must lay
under the earth of quick stop because
something [ __ ] up happened here years
ago and i have a career so like
let's make sure that career keeps going
let's lay those lines again
so we decided to open up [ __ ] smog
castle and it's got bugs
um but um
so last night being the opening night
was wonderful tonight being night two
is absolutely historic especially with
us being able to do this so if you're at
home and you're watching and [ __ ]
uh come on down to smog castle if you
get a chance but we got a show to do
so we should dive into it the big
question we were having before the show
began and the people here in the
audience heard us having this like
backstage conversation is we have
sponsors tonight
but i feel like i've done a lot of
advertising already so like i don't do
we
i mean they're not sitting there going
boy i hope they're [ __ ] gonna do
their ad tonight
are they do you think we get away with
not doing it
are you asking me
oh batman is here ladies and gentlemen
i uh i don't think will wilkins will be
very happy about it if we skip
it billy he'd be like let's see i'm
gonna leave my phone open if we'll texts
if we'll text will just stop the show
and do some ads
like it will text then i'll know it's
[ __ ] serious man because sometimes i
don't even think will's watching the
[ __ ] show
so if he texts we'll know it's important
and then we'll have to bust some [ __ ]
ads
what i would like to get to is the
goddamn content because i'm very eager
to talk about
the movie that i watched uh did you
watch the movie that i watched
uh luca luke is adorable
not that fish [ __ ] no man i'm another
mother
flipper it's it's it's two dudes who are
in love and there's a girl who gets in
the way
and it's adorable um i'm talking about
[ __ ] black widow did you watch mark
widow oh that one yes
i watched that one too
ladies and gentlemen will wilken says
please don't skip the ads
[Laughter]
well we could do the ad we could do
here's what we could do
keeps no native after we talk about
black widow and loki before the news
and then we do keeps before q a how does
that work sounds like a plan it helps to
have adults in the room and apparently
between you and will somebody's like
somebody's got to pay for this [ __ ] here
we are doing [ __ ]
uh live ads ladies and gentlemen and boy
i couldn't be happier for the live ad
we're about to do
you see how i turned that [ __ ] on uh
this week ladies and gentlemen
uh the first we got two sponsors as you
probably heard
but the first half of the show this top
half of the show um
is going to be brought to you by the
good folks i literally forgot who it is
already
don't [ __ ] tell me the good folks
that [ __ ] native go to nativedeo.com
ladies and gentlemen
follow along as mark tells us all about
native go mark
yeah do you hate things that stink of
course you do
native cares about the products you put
in your body they're about stopping the
stink
the right way that's the native
difference you probably know
all about their legendary aluminum free
deodorant but they got body wash and
toothpaste
and they got their own mineral based
sunscreen yes
native now has broad spectrum spf 30
sunscreen for your face and body no i'm
going big just let let me be
cut might need another take on that
[ __ ]
yes yes i'm
i'm filling the space let me feel the
space
in space here let me help let me help
you sell native man all right get in
there
get true [ __ ] story never mind that
ad copy that mark is brilliantly
performing for us man
i had a native [ __ ] crossover in real
life uh this week i just came out to
jersey we're here for the summer and
stuff
uh so me and jennifer my wife i went to
target to buy a bunch of [ __ ]
supplies and stuff
and she literally pulled me out of an
aisle
into a side aisle to be like they have
my products
and her products were [ __ ] native man
and so i was like
i get that [ __ ] for free and she's like
i'm gonna pay for it and she bought
all the same native [ __ ] that we have
for free at home which we could have
sent out she was like how are we gonna
get it to us i was like fedex and she's
like you've lost
perspective and she bought native right
at [ __ ] target like
anybody [ __ ] can but here on the show
we actually send him to the website is
that correct
we do and also why did you let me read
that [ __ ] if you had your own great
story ready to go
like what the [ __ ]
just want to make sure the connection's
working
figured yes so native deo kids now go to
nativedeo.com
mark's going to tell you about what a
[ __ ] brilliant deal they're going to
offer you tell them mark
indeed if you stay fresh and stay clean
with native go to native deo slash
nativedeo.com fat man or use the code
fat fatman at checkout and get 20
off your first order i'm sorry i gotta
[ __ ] check because this could be a
bad line from across the country
did you say 20 off two
zero percent off let me tell you
something that's better than a [ __ ]
no but it's 20 off
most [ __ ] honest and quickest
as if response suggested it before and
[ __ ] he's like for the last time that's
not true
um we thank the good folks at native uh
deodorant
uh uh for sponsoring fat man on batman
go to nativedeo.com batman right now
or enter the promo code fat man is it
just batman or batman
just fat man at checkout for 20 off your
first order
20 [ __ ] percent off to stink less man
we thank the good folks
at nativedeodorand.com they're making
this all possible give it up for native
deodorant kids
will wilkins said thank you
apparently he does watch the show man he
does like doing nine other things and
just checks in and stuff but he's legit
watching
i like that you got to play santa claus
for will just then it's like oh
will is a happy boy it takes so little
to make people happy he's like please
help me get paid yeah and now he's happy
um all right mark are you ready to talk
about it let's talk about it
uh after a year or more of waiting
marvel uh finally put a black widow out
there some people of course went to see
it in the theater
i watched on disney plus what did you do
mark
i similarly disney plus it i could not
make it to the theater on friday
um because it said pitch meeting
so instead this morning at uh at 11
o'clock i i heated up the old disney
plus
and uh and paid my money and watched my
widow um
and uh for those in the audience
um how many people have not
with the show of putting your hands
together how many people have not
seen black widow yet
for those who have seen black widow put
your hands together
real quick
those are gonna hear the applause so i
don't know what that really was right
there ladies and gentlemen
um yeah how does one do this normally i
don't think about this because i'm at
home
and i don't hear people going oh man
shut up but like
we may be spoiling it for some folks in
this room now of the percentage of
people that didn't
see it yet how many of those people are
like oh i'm not seeing it is not a
priority to me put your hands together
real quick
what the [ __ ]
what are you sleeping on this [ __ ] for
man i mean to be fair it came out
yesterday a few people have been like
we've been with you all weekend i've
been
i still watch the [ __ ] movies so
yeah i'm not gonna spoil anything the
excuses here in the room is hotel
internet sucks
um i had some pretty decent internet so
i watch it
sorry kids we're gonna have to spoil
this uh to talk about it so
i won't i'm not gonna spoil anything i'm
gonna i'm gonna do spoiler free
because it's been for 24 hours dude
guys got a point we're talking about
this movie like nobody's gonna know what
happens it's [ __ ] titanic with people
right like
we know she's gonna hit the iceberg by
the third [ __ ] act because she ain't
in the universe no more that's a good
point
um yeah i guess we could kind of try to
talk about without spoilers but
i want to get into the nitty-gritty but
i'd like to i'll follow your lead
if you think that works yeah i i feel
like we can definitely
dodge around some of the some of the
stuff i think we could do it i feel good
about us
kids we got uh we got weird [ __ ] on our
monitor up here
christian well you might want to give us
a [ __ ] heads up
we know what a great excuse um all right
the house is on fire oh we know yeah
we're well aware tell your funny jokes
um all right my friend let's walk into
it your thoughts
um i really enjoyed it i i enjoyed it
more than i expected to because
natasha coming off my [ __ ] review i
went into this one where i'm like
you know i'll see it because i'm a
completionist
but the first 10 minutes i was like this
this [ __ ] company's going
i place really know how to open a movie
i don't know why
i ever have this thought anymore where
i'm like i don't know if that's going to
be the one for me
like yeah i talked about on one of the
other shows i'm like i'm totally going
to see
you know [ __ ] the eternals but like i
have no emotional connection to the
material i never read the book growing
up
even as an adult so you know this one
i'm not as jazzed for stuff at least
black widow
i had some sort of skin in the game but
after
like seeing end game it's kind of weird
knowing that like well unless they're
gonna bring her back to life if this is
a story set in the past
i know she's probably gonna make it out
alive just to die
[ __ ] later on and stuff so i didn't
have high expectations because i was
like i think i know what to expect even
if i don't know what the story is
i forgot that these cats are like master
[ __ ] chefs right
so like even though i figured i had all
the recipes and i knew i wasn't making
the exact one in my head that they made
i was like yeah i know where this is
going i didn't know where it was going
they [ __ ] gripped me
in the first like [ __ ] few minutes
and like you said
i it was not the movie i was expecting
and because of that
i loved it for the first 90 minutes i
absolutely loved the movie and that's
not to put down the last whatever the
[ __ ]
but it was just i won't watch the first
90 minutes in a row and then i had to
come do
stuff here and then and then when i went
back
like at night it wasn't like oh this
part doesn't [ __ ] i guess we'll talk
about it in a minute but it was just
like the momentum had kind of fallen off
from me not by virtue of the movie
uh because of something else but i i too
was surprised by how much i like it
that's not to say that like
i'm shocked that scarlett johansson can
carry a movie i've loved her in many
things
but like the idea that there would be a
black widow movie that followed endgame
where we all know that she gave up her
life and [ __ ] like that and never mind
her part in endgame end game being
marvel universe it's just tough for
any movie to [ __ ] come out after it
and be like okay this is the next marvel
movie
and god damn it without covid this movie
would have stuck
the landing it still sticks the landing
now but like it would have worked
less than a year after end game do you
agree i keep looking at the modern i
should look at
uh i i totally do you know i i
i like you the first like 10 minutes
when you're you know this isn't that
much of a spoiler but it's the sort of
the origin of this family unit that we
sort of come to meet and get invested in
you know natasha her sister elena
and her parents alexi and what's her
mom's name
i can't remember molina molina
um you know and a lot of attention man
yeah well played
not even like a top tier character or
something i'm like oh it's her
yeah i was rachel vice who the the
amazing rachel vice
um and so the the movie is it's like two
things it's both spycraft it's a lot of
natasha
you know black widow league like doing a
swirly kick around people and bring them
to the ground
and and international espionage and then
it's also this really lovely kind of
family connection story
about all these people who were kind of
broken in service of a country
and how they you know where their lives
led them and how they find a way to get
back together and so
for me i i you know the the spy stuff
was fun the action stuff is fun enough
but that middle chunk like in most of it
is built around this
dinner that they have in in molina's
like
pig farm is wonderful like in a way that
i didn't expect it to be
like moving in a way i didn't expect it
to be like i did not expect to be
sitting there
watching hopper from stranger things
sing american pie
and bring tears to my eyes because
emotional about it where you're just
like oh my god this is crazy touching
yeah and like i i haven't seen pew and
anything else i never saw midsummer i
never saw a little woman
um so this is the first time i've
actually seen her and she's phenomenal
you know and so if if the enterprise of
black widow
is to introduce elena her character into
the mcu
then it was an enterprise worth doing
you know because
based on to spoil that she is going to
be
further in the mcu yeah if you
especially watch the end credits scene
they make it very [ __ ] clear that
that's not the last we see of her and
this
and not so i guess we can do it without
spoiling it watching this
end credit scene this was the very first
end credit scene
that didn't hand off to a movie as much
as
expressly handed off to a disney plush
show did you notice that
yeah yeah i mean because granted the
other movies we'd seen
i mean i don't know did they have they
didn't have any disney i mean
i guess we had talked about there having
been you know a wan division or we maybe
knew there was a [ __ ] winter soldier
show
after end game but there was nothing
forward nothing there to hand off
now that's going to be part of it going
forward at this point like they could
either hand off to one of the features
or hand off to like whatever the show is
going to be next um
and the handoff was nice i again i don't
want to spoil it for people but like
the handoff made me interested in the
character
that they were handing off to for like
the first time
you're like i was like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'll watch that if it's all about that
[ __ ] trying to kill that [ __ ]
now i care about him um let me ask you
this because this is where
i had my third act stumble and it's no
fault of the movie whatsoever
um it's it's based on
assumption uh you know that i've gotten
from the net
did oh [ __ ] and this spoils things too
god damn it [ __ ] you people who didn't
watch it
i think how to do this without doing it
spoil it all right kids if you're gonna
you can hear muffin if you're in the
room if you're home and you haven't
watched it
gonna spoil a little bit of uh
of uh black widow very specifically
uh uh one of the bad guys cover yours
and stuff
and if you're here in the audience and
you're covering yours don't look at me
because you might accidentally lip read
and [ __ ] like that
um here we go did
do you remember rumors
of who task master was
for like two years like in production or
even a year ago when they started
showing art and stuff
did you ever hear this is my
to me i thought it was common knowledge
that there was somebody
who was going to be task master did
let's start there did you ever
hear rumors about who was really task
master i i never did but i also
you know kind of sidestepped as much of
that kind of
you know onset rumor mill if i can um
because rarely is it right
and even if it's right does that make it
a better watch for me later on down the
road does that
does that sap some of the juice of
watching the finished
product if i know too much about it
going in it's an occupational hazard
that we all have but i'm like if i can
avoid it why not avoid it
so like you don't think the article on
the internet was accurate
sometimes it isn't so what
is he-man really in our show
nope honestly it's not just one article
it wasn't speculation from one website
i was under the assumption that
everybody
knew and again i'm going to try to keep
this very oblique but
anybody in the room know what i'm
talking about
does anybody in the room know
anything else about that story like this
is what it read like to me
based on having heard those old rumors
it felt like they had a year off
and they were like [ __ ] it let's just
change the movie and
changed who one of the characters was
did it read like that to anybody else
didn't hurt the movie one iota as far as
i was concerned i wasn't like i was
[ __ ] ruin it but it really
i i was sure that there was one
character who was going to be the
villain
that was not and i was [ __ ]
completely thrown by that
and who did you think it was we can
spoil that since it isn't
that was like the most honest no i've
heard in a long time like no
don't spoil it and [ __ ] go to the
bathroom so we could talk like adults
so the adults can talk about their
children things um
yeah i don't i don't i mean you heard
the passion there
i i don't want to spoil it but there you
didn't
but if it's not a thing that happened
how is that a spoiler
is it some weird alternate universe
sliding door spoiler and it becomes a
spoiler
for what it's not
i don't know what i'm saying because if
we say the name then people watching the
movie
instantly eliminate that person as a
potential
they're telling me to stop blue ball on
the mark what do i do i've never faced
that
it doesn't happen at my house check he
loves me um
all right here we go again [ __ ] i'm
sorry if you haven't watched if you're
at home
and you're like ah cover yours and [ __ ]
i i was i was [ __ ] sure that rachel
vice was task master was i alone in that
i i didn't hear that i'm not crazy like
i literally as i watched the movie
i was like we are in a different
timeline i felt like it was that
bernstein berenstein bears thing where
i'm i'm like no
everybody knows it's going to be rachel
vice and when it wasn't i was like
what the [ __ ] and not in a bad way where
i was like this movie sucks but i'm like
what has happened to my mind like i
literally thought i woke up in another
dimension
where they did a different ending in the
movie i thought i left our [ __ ]
timeline mark
i don't but i don't like yeah i suppose
you could have
originally planned to do that and have
her be both taskmaster
and natasha's mother and but
well mother about quote-unquote mother i
mean i i
yeah i suppose you could have done that
and that would have played and yes to
make that not
natash not uh what is it melania
yeah yeah i mean it's it's a couple of i
mean yeah you got to rebuild that
building and you've got to redo this
thing and you've got to change the
identity
it's doable but it feels like that
family scene was so much
always a part of the movie um
that yeah no
i guess you know what i'm saying like it
wouldn't have been out of character
for them to still have that family scene
and for
you know her to go rogue at the end and
be revealed as as the bad guy
and i'm again not disappointed they
didn't do it but i'm
i for some reason i thought we all
[ __ ] knew that
like and it's not true i mean you know
i'm sure if i called my mother she'd be
like
i'm thinking about not dying goodnight
tiger and [ __ ] like that but like
i thought anybody that cares about this
[ __ ]
thought that like it was a kind of a
mind [ __ ] for me and again did not ruin
the movie one iota but
it actually took it out of exactly where
i thought it was going where i was like
oh i know it's gonna happen and sooner
or later she's gonna pull the mask off
and it's
[ __ ] rachel vice and then it wasn't
and i was like holy [ __ ] like all right
i better pay more attention yeah now i
appreciated that
um because i think marvel especially
marvel tv and we'll talk about it when
we talk about loki
has has kind of fallen into this mystery
villain
trope a little bit where it's always
who's the bad guy
we'll find out later and at some point
it will be agatha all along it'll be the
power brokel all along it will be
to the elbow with mephisto um
so like i yeah there it is we used that
one together and when they did they were
like that's dirty
[Laughter]
so i appreciated like there not being a
giant mystery about who taskmaster was
and having it be so i'm like
it's her mom quotes like i i like that
it was just taskmaster and it meant
something to your bad guy
but it didn't need to mean anything and
it did mean something to your hero a
little bit more i suppose that you know
the guilt of it all still plays
great that's why i was like not
unsatisfied i was like oh that's [ __ ]
kind of dope man and then suddenly i was
like
you know again like as somebody who
tells stories for a living you think you
could see the [ __ ] strings and you're
like well that's a setup and it'll get
paid off
like they gave us the setup and it was
loud as [ __ ] but i was
so busy looking like it was a you know
[ __ ] three-card monty i was so busy
watching the card that i assumed was the
[ __ ] card
they gave me all the information to
figure this [ __ ] out myself and still i
was like couldn't be that move aside
so it's actually like well done but
banff man jump in here real quick
i want to see if the internet has any
[ __ ] thoughts on the subject
anybody agreeing with that bam
most of uh most of the internet just
muted the show
if they didn't want to uh to hear
anything in
any of the spoilers so that's mostly
what i'm seeing that's [ __ ] pretty
awesome man they just muted the show
thank god they didn't leave they weren't
like [ __ ] this
they're asking me to let them know when
we move on to loki
because they don't want to get spoiled
well is there anybody
like going like he's out of his [ __ ]
mind i never heard that or
was there a lot of agreement there was a
a lot of agreement that um
journalists were speculating that that's
who the bad guy was but
uh nobody said that they heard it as
like inside info
interesting um god the internet just
works on me man like [ __ ]
i think i'm like it's [ __ ] true i
read it
um all right i i really [ __ ] enjoyed
it man despite the fact that like the
third act or
the tail end of the movie was not what i
was building in my head
and again not in a bad way where i'm
like oh my ending would have been better
i was delighted that they actually
[ __ ] threw me and i didn't think that
was kind of possible
not to take anything away from marvel
they're amazing storytellers but like
you know there's
tropes that can be followed in comic
book movies that have to be followed and
[ __ ] and so
i thought i was reading all the tropes
correctly completely misread it as such
i
loved the first 90 minutes of it and was
baffled and then still enjoyed
uh the last 30 minutes uh
how how did what was your what's your
final summation mark
um you know like it's i'm glad we got
this movie i'm glad that it
we were able to fill in some of these
blanks for natasha romanoff and i'm glad
that it's
it is going to have repercussions into
the mcu going forward which i was always
kind of concerned about was is this just
this bottle episode
that that has no impact and the mcu is
all about impact it's all about the
gathering storms and all about rolling
the stones and so
um i was you know i was really impressed
by it
um and it was emotional in a way i
didn't expect it to be
you know because sort of the death of
natasha ramanov
in endgame spoilers um was a pretty big
moment
um and so to be able to give her
finally even after that moment you know
sort of her moment the sun
um was uh yeah i really really
appreciated it and again like
florence pugh you know get to follow her
um and i think it's public knowledge
that she's in the hawkeye cast
um so but you know they were like she's
joining hawkeye
yeah so i think i think we we do sort of
understand a little bit
about her trajectory going forward um
and and i love that there's that little
call back
and it's in a scene that i'm not going
to spoil but
uh it's it's a callback to the very
first avengers
movie when when black widow gets the
best of loki
you know and it's you you think she's on
her heels you think that loki's winning
and then it's
thank you for your cooperation yeah they
kind of show that like she's a very
strategic fighter but she doesn't just
use her muscles she can fight with her
mind and [ __ ]
you're right i've read that i didn't
realize that part man um
right on so marvel does it again [ __ ]
when will they leave mark when will they
get off the ball is it possible uh
you know anything is possible but uh it
does not seem likely at this point
uh which leads directly into loki you
watched that as well
i did i did i took the journey into
mystery
uh which a great title reference to uh
old marvel title that
uh the characters appeared in and stuff
the uh
the last week's episode not the week
that just passed and
stuff but the week before where we got
the reveal the time keepers
seemed like a lot happened uh this
episode seemed like less happened than
the previous episode although there's a
big
reveal at the end uh what were your
thoughts my friend
um i think this was my favorite episode
of the show so far
that right yeah you know i think that
it's beginning to answer some questions
you know in that
ultimately what is loki here for what is
loki looking for well and and
the timekeepers is just a handy sort of
mcguffin that he's after but emotionally
what does loki want
and it's clear that loki doesn't want to
be alone you know
and he has been his entire time he's
betrayed everybody who might have stuck
with him and so he's finally turned that
corner
into realizing that i i can't i don't
just want to survive i need to live
you know and to see the the very i mean
i'm
you give me richard grant in a kermit
the frog costume and giant helmets
i'm i will watch 60 minutes of that and
just be pleased as punch
and so richard grant is classic loki you
know you got kid loki and black loki and
alligator loki and little frog
you know sort of buried between the
layers which was apparently voiced by
chris hemsworth
which i thought was adorable what yes
chris hemsworth did the voice of throg
yep
um in there is one moment in logie where
they're traveling through the earth like
simpsons cartoon style where you see
dead things and things have been hidden
in the earth for a long time
and i watched on the phone first in the
morning and so i didn't see that detail
um it wasn't until later on the internet
told me that throgg was in it i was like
[ __ ] and i watched it again blew it
up i was like it's [ __ ] frog
i didn't know that he was the voice
where'd you hear that um i think
thr or or or maybe ign
reported it out um but yeah which i just
found adorable and like
the deep cuts of of the marvel comics
uh continuity like the thanos helicopter
yes you know it's like guys in the
comics kids
uh when they were doing infinity
gauntlet i think didn't he [ __ ]
travel around from time to time
on a helicopter that said thanos on the
side
it first appeared in 1979 in spitey
super stories number 39
where he's legit flying around in a
thanos helicopter
um so low-key he's written his name on
the side but that was in that was in the
uh
the background of the where are they
what are they calling that place yeah
the void
is all they call it you know and eliath
is also you know a big comic book
character
which does tie kind of into the kang the
conqueror of it all
so i liked i like sort of where they're
pushing you know they're
and then the silvi loki story which
feels like it's a little bit romantic
which also feels kind of skeevy because
they're either brother and sister or the
same thing and so is it just
masturbation
or are they falling in love are they
just friends or
unclear but at least we know what he
wants
and he knows that that sylvie is the
other side of it
um i i didn't love that death seems to
mean nothing in this
universe like you you give agent mobius
like this kind of
like shocking send-off and then he's
back the very next episode
you know you give loki this very
surprisingly did they just kill [ __ ]
loki that's ballsy and then he's back
the very next episode like you kind of
want there to be some repercussions to
actions and
and the show doesn't seem to do that
unless what they're pointing to
is that agent mobius is a loki and has
been the whole time
and loki's survive
you just [ __ ] broke my brain
that's why you [ __ ] have mark
bernardin on your show ladies and
gentlemen because he sees [ __ ] you don't
see i didn't [ __ ] see that that's
fantastic man i also liked how you broke
down the loneliness [ __ ] i didn't see
that even though he literally talks
about being lonely and [ __ ]
hence if it's like you will always be
alone you know he's like i wonder what
that means
well it takes uh mark to kind of break
it down uh do you think it was
chronopolis that we saw at the end
um i i would believe that it seems as if
we're we're pushing
um we're pushing in that direction
although i will be upset
i'm gonna mark my words i will be upset
if kang
is the big um sort of string puller at
the end yo
you won't like if it's gang i won't
because
kang means nothing to any of the
characters we've been following
kang only works for us the audience loki
doesn't know who kang is
you know mobius doesn't know who king is
sylvia doesn't know who kanye so if kang
steps out says i've been doing this all
alone like well who are you now
and what you want is only like fanboys
like oh my god [ __ ] kang did it i
knew it but the rest of the people who
don't follow this [ __ ] would be like
who's that
yeah that means nothing to me so you
want it to be somebody who means
something to these characters you want
to be somebody
who we've been i mean it's [ __ ] like
procedural writing where
the bad guy is always a person you met
in the second act
like you know it's every every law and
order every cop show when they do their
interviewing of people
you have to have seen the person along
that interview trail in order for that
to make sense
it's always like the third person he's
[ __ ] right man like i just went
through all the lauren orders in my head
and you always beat the bad person like
in the middle of the episode
yeah it just can't come out of nowhere
for as much tv as i've watched
like tv writing is still fascinating
that's [ __ ] abc bro and i'm like
that's brilliant
you're right that's true loki variant
i've
never [ __ ] crossed my mind whatsoever
you know and i also think that ravona
renslayer
uh judge ravona might also be a loki
they're all [ __ ] lokies um the only
reason i think she's a loki and i think
she's the bad guy
which is where they're pointing or it's
the [ __ ]
miss minutes hologram computer thing the
person
that guy the cartoon bad guy which would
also be kind of badass
is poochie her helper
um who so you think it's going to wind
up being one of those and
if it wound up being kang you wouldn't
be like oh that [ __ ] rocks you'd be
like
dumb storytelling yeah or just it's not
emotional to anybody
it's just data me i'm like my
childhood's back
it's here um wow man
perspective the one that i didn't have
what do you think happens in this very
last episode do you think it's just
ravono revealed as a bad guy
um you know i i think it's ravona
because
that's where they're pushing is ravona
real is the bag or are these ravono
wanting the same thing that they want
and now
also like the race for chronopolis and
who's who's who's behind all of this
and why ravono is willing to cover it up
um
we only have an hour left
not on this show but on their [ __ ]
show for them to tie up
all those details and then thread the
needle for what's next
yeah i mean i don't i i completely
believe
that kang is the post credit sequence
you know that like you wrap up the story
story and then you
nod you then pass off to ant-man 3
with oh [ __ ] it's kang kang's doing this
why is kang doing this who's kang
after and then that leads you into
quantum mania
man you're [ __ ] good at this dude
like
in that marvel room and [ __ ] plotting
things that absolutely [ __ ] makes
sense
um all right uh we got one more episode
it happens what on wednesday
next wednesday and then what after
loki's done nothing until
hawkeye nothing until what if which we
saw the first trailer of
and the trailer which of course we can't
show unless we be thrown off a [ __ ]
youtube let's not get crazy
got to show a clip of something we tried
to show a [ __ ] clip of the he-man
trailer of masters
universe show and they were like you
don't have the authority to do this i
was like i'm the [ __ ] show runner and
[ __ ] so
won't try to show the [ __ ] trailer
but we will talk about that what if
charlie
does that tie up loki and black widow
it does for me both on disney plus kids
they're not a sponsor but we love what
they're doing go watch those [ __ ]
shows um
this brings us into the news doesn't it
it does indeed
ladies and gentlemen mark bernardin is
not only one of the best [ __ ] writers
you'll hear tonight
he's also a [ __ ] guy that used to
cover the goddamn news man he's a new
sound and even though
he's gone on to more creative pastures
news
is still in his blood man he went and
found some news for us to talk about
give it up for mark bernard with the
news
hey so marvel put out the new what if
trailer what uh wither
what do you got uh it's you know i think
what if the trailer for what if
and the fact that we get our first look
at the new guardians of the galaxy um
which
seems to be focused around t'challa
who which was voiced apparently um in
one of his last if not his last role
chadwick boseman wow which you know like
that voice sounds familiar or they got a
really good double for his voice and
he's like no that's him
and uh all of the characters are they're
using the real actors like i saw
tony stark is that i don't know if
that's rdj or if that's just
you know yeah it didn't quite sound like
rdj
um uh but i think that might be chris
hemsworth because that did sound like
hemsworth
it definitely sounded like michael b
jordan um
who's done like animation voices before
so it doesn't surprise me
right um but the idea that we're getting
you know iron killmonger
um is pretty great the fact that you're
getting yondu and t'challa
roaming through the universe as the
star-lord is pretty great
captain carter looks pretty great um
you know like we've seen some of the
captain carter stuff before but i
i didn't quite comprehend the breath of
the stories that they were telling
and uh i'm super excited for it like it
looks great
never mind the stories the stories are
cool what if formula's been around
forever
uh you know marvel had the book for
years and years so it's a winning
formula that most people have never
really touched before in terms of
anthology and it works very
very insanely well in the marvel
universe because they created it that
being said
i was always going to be on board
because like oh this is stories about
[ __ ] that could happen or didn't happen
and whatnot
nobody ever told me it would be one of
the most beautiful things i've ever seen
in my life this cartoon is
[ __ ] stunning it looks like you know
uh
spider-man into the spider-verse times
10 across the boards everything about it
looks like it was animated in like the
[ __ ] 40s or the 50s and i mean that
in the best possible way like it looks
max spicer [ __ ] good
what about you yeah now there's there's
that sequence where
captain carter is like
lit backlit by headlights of a truck and
it's just
gorgeous because the light is spilling
in weird ways and
and the character the characters don't
feel like they have weight and that's
kind of what you want
you know especially if you're looking
for likenesses and you're looking for
something that feels like reality that
you can still push
into into the into the unreal i think it
looks amazing i think it sounds great
and yeah those the short like 23 minute
nuggets of stories
is a perfect way for us to just dip into
these what-if stories
that [ __ ] headlight shot is more
cinematic and more
visually uh like accomplished and
gorgeous than anything i've ever put in
an actual [ __ ] movie man
and it's a cartoon but it's like don't
forget this is a cartoon made by the
people that practically [ __ ] invented
the art form man it's coming from the
house of disney so i guess we all should
have expected that it would be
kind of stunning add to it that it's
marvel and marvel's never gonna just
step
out there with something kind of normal
and whatnot so i guess we should have
expected how beautiful it would be but
when i watched the trailer i mean i'd
seen footage before but when i watched
this
this trailer the longer trailer it's
[ __ ] sumptuous
just [ __ ] gorgeous made me appreciate
like the time that we're living in i
grew up reading what if comics and they
were always so [ __ ] fun to read
because it's like
they don't [ __ ] with continuity it's all
about what if and stuff
getting to and re-enjoy it now like in
my
old age in a stunning visual format like
this [ __ ] looks better than when i read
some of the original stories
um it's it's one of those tell you know
like people go like what a great time to
be alive and [ __ ]
like that's what i felt like when i saw
that trailer i was like i can't believe
i've lived long enough
to see this i almost died a few years
ago from a [ __ ] heart attack
and i was like i would have missed this
[ __ ] cartoon
that's jennifer and she's like your
perspective is all [ __ ] shot
but it's so [ __ ] good looking when
does this begin
august 11th we get the first of 10
episodes
um your folks on the internet are like
stop blowing marvel but it's like you
know what
i will when their come stops tasting so
[ __ ] good
yes because my god they can do no
[ __ ] wrong so
far maybe what black widow to me just
made me more excited or excited
literally for the first time
about the eternals because i'm like if
this is [ __ ] engaging like you know
they're never gonna
whiff like never well i guess sooner or
later everybody whiffs but like
sooner or later they gotta make their
cars too you know what i'm saying
so we'll see if that ever happens right
now a lot of people out there with kids
are like [ __ ] you i like cars too
i've seen it 400 times it's just fine
yeah but like you made clerks too shut
the [ __ ] up
um until they [ __ ] up like make mine
marvel man they're [ __ ] doing it and
no they don't pay me i'm not a show i
just [ __ ] love what they're doing
they've knocked me down yet i rue the
day
that they do let me down because you
know how hardcore fans go from being
like i love this [ __ ] to like
they're [ __ ] dead to me like
that day uh what other news we got mark
um speaking of marvel um even though
they
they keep giving and they keep giving
they are not giving us any
new film footage or any presentations
uh nor is dc films at san diego comic
con at home
they're skipping the virtual um
convention this year
and they're going to withhold whatever
first looks they have for some later
date
second year in a row i believe if not
the third yeah second year in a row
um and some of it is because yeah they
they maximize
the attendance in hall age they maximize
the
the sort of market buzz that it creates
and and the online version of san diego
just doesn't quite equate
for them and meanwhile like these cats
are doing their own
online festivals like netflix did
geeked week uh did as well as a d24
or whatever 23. you know and last year
one
[ __ ] number to that man um and then
mar
what did warner brothers do they did
their dc fan dome
they did last year right so now people
are like we can do this [ __ ]
on our own particularly if we're doing
it from home so wow
i know we did a master's in the universe
netflix panel
that they did for uh that's coming i
guess for san diego comic-con
but yeah i'd heard early on that like
because i asked i was like oh [ __ ] is
marvel going to show anything but like
not again
i was like wow you think they're going
to return i mean i think they will once
you get
you know 140 000 people back
in um in san diego or they might they
might be saving their keeping their
powder drive for new york comic con
which should be back in person in
october
and even then though before the
quarantine you remember like marvel
didn't go once or twice to san diego
didn't do a presentation
you know mainly because we were like in
production and didn't have anything to
present but
they have been known to step away from
the con can you imagine
being a genre film and you're so [ __ ]
big that you don't even need the san
diego comic-con to open your movie
it feels like that's where they've
gotten to yeah i mean
d23 is also a very good um birth for
that which is
it's our house we we control everything
we control when we go on we control who
we let
into the house we can control all of it
and you know it helps to just reinforce
the disney brand
so yeah there's the version where they
do that and i'm not even sure when the
next day 23 is supposed to be
but at the very least we're going to
it's going to be a while before we see
footage
of uh spider-man no way home or even
hell no that's that's sony marvel so
that sony hasn't decided yet
about the uh see all that from the c23
is this year
it's usually every year it's not quite
like star wars celebration
but i remember when it is doing a small
one in orlando hold on i'm getting
information live mark stand by
okay hold on it's coming in now go ahead
tell me
two days i'll get i can only do a piece
of information at a [ __ ] time man
hold on
hold on i gotta convey to him he can't
hear uh d23
keep going check
stop just a few words at a time either
in september or
october it's coming through now khan
at the contemporary hotel there's a
convention center as well
uh the conventionary convention
contemporary convention center
the the news has been broken
excellent thank you appreciate our man
in the field i am young source you
should get credit
it's patrick give it up for patrick
everybody
um all right mark what other news we got
did you see a tomorrow war
the tomorrow war i still i i hear
i yes yes and no i started watching it
but i was really tired as no
no slag against the movie but uh we had
watched three movies me and jen
and then she was like oh what about the
chris pratt movie on amazon
and it was like 11 o'clock at night and
i was like yeah let's [ __ ] do it
and like 10 minutes in i was already
kind of falling asleep and it's not by
any fault of the movie
because i kept being woken up by my wife
being like oh this [ __ ] rhymes which
she never does man she was so
into the [ __ ] flick and she's
mentioned it several times since she
watched it she was like i really like
that
you really should have stayed awake and
i was like well we could have watched it
the next day and she's like
you're starting to become an old man
going to sleep all early that's when the
good movies are on and i'm like
they're on when we put them on like this
it's not the [ __ ] 70s
and [ __ ] but still um i did there's a
long way of saying it
i watched i understand the premise but i
have to go back and watch the whole
movie what i saw i did enjoy it yourself
i i have seen none of it yet i it came
out july 2nd over fourth of july weekend
and i opted instead for my batman beyond
we talk about the movies we both enjoyed
indeed um i i instead opted for my
ceremonial annual viewing of
independence day on independence day
weekend
that you did yeah because every year i
watch it
you know for the most part
it it's just it's amazing that at this
point like you don't meet will smith
until like 40 minutes into that movie
is that right yeah there's there's a
long you know whole
protracted draw nothing like you don't
need him until the alien ships are
overhead and that's like
the end of the first act and so thinks
of him as the star of the movie
yeah i mean it's it's jeff goldblum is
the star of that movie and like
judd hirsch
nobody ever wants to have their name
read aloud in that fashion
[Laughter]
hold on it's coming through judd hirsch
what um does the do the effects
hold up because i rewatched uh matrix
uh with my wife and then i was like oh
my god that rocked let's watch matrix
two and we got about five minutes in but
the first one man we were
like [ __ ] absolutely in love with and
this is no
slag on the movie the the wachowskis are
brilliant filmmakers better than i'll
ever be and that movie is groundbreaking
and historical and
and uh absolutely iconic that being said
when was the last time you re-watched
the matrix
a couple years back i think first time i
like really noticed the strings where i
was like
oh this was made in like 1999
so like like some of the effect
shots look like effect shots whereas now
we're absolutely used to
seamless like things that happen almost
seem like they're happening for real
but there are a few shots in there where
you can see the
composition put together a layer upon
layer and stuff
um so as as modern as is that like the
[ __ ] hunter killers all the all the
bullet time all this [ __ ] jumping up in
the air turn around cameras
all that [ __ ] looks [ __ ] astounding
it still holds up and stuff but there
are moments
standard movie making [ __ ] that like
this is the best
anybody could do in the 90s because this
was the technology at that point
like i noticed those scenes for the
first [ __ ] time yeah i mean
i i feel like independence day is a lot
like jurassic park
in that they did as much as they could
with as little as they needed to
like jurassic park has 40 45
cg shots in the whole thing like most of
that movie's practical and then the cg
stuff
is when you need it's when you have
velociraptors jumping up on
on counters and stuff and so i think
that the cg in in
in independence day is just with like
fighter
jets flying up against alien you know
little wizzy bug things
everything else is like miniatures
everything else is like very smart old
school like when you blow up the white
house
it's a baby white house on somebody's
lawn that they then blew up
so it sells it that way the scale of it
sells it and so it's
it holds together better than i thought
it would
how can i um all of that is to say
i did not see tomorrow war um but uh
tomorrow
war two apparently is coming because
based on its performance and its opening
weekend
where another thing that's coming based
on that my wife she loved that [ __ ]
tomorrow
movie so much when i go home and tell
her there's gonna be a two she's gonna
be like oh prat and just [ __ ]
wet her pants man she really enjoyed
that flick you and i are apparently
sleeping on this [ __ ] thing
did it get a lot of views is that why
they're already doing two
yeah apparently it was the the number
one film across
um the entire industry as far as you
know
social and and conversation metrics go
it was amazon's biggest viewer movie
ever it beat out
um um tom clancy's without remorse and
borat
um especially in its opening weekend and
so for
whatever metric that amazon needs to
greenlight things which again remember
whatever they're spending on movies is a
drop in the bucket compared to what
they're making on toilet paper
and uh and and like cloud drives
most of the amazon's revenue is based on
on cloud sharing
from the people who sell you bounty yes
yeah like yeah they they bought it from
skydance for 200 million dollars and
they could care less because one dude's
going to the moon
is that what they did they bought it for
200 bucks 200 million bucks
yep so they didn't even make that they
just acquired it and they
just they're like we can acquire huge
[ __ ] movies
yeah i mean same thing with without
remorse which they acquired from
paramount and coming to america
um which they made none of it was like a
you know it was a pandemic fire sale and
they just bought a bunch of movies for a
boatload of money
you know the premise of tomorrow award
do you know what i know they like
can you um elaborate
i can't articulate on it well beyond
what i gleaned from the trailers which
is
um at some point soldiers from 40 years
in the future come to the past to
recruit a bunch of dudes to fight
because they're fighting a losing war
against invading aliens that track the
first 10 minutes that i remember
it is something like that and i was like
cool premise
um all right we gotta check that out
what other news um
once upon a time maybe about a decade
ago zack snyder
wanted to make a star wars movie really
yeah no he he he grew up as an akira
kurosawa fan and as a star wars fan
and you know he went to had meetings
with lucasfilm
um it was a bit more mature than you
know lucas
had ever envisioned and so the
conversations kind of
disappeared when walt disney acquired
lucasfilm in 2012.
um but he'd always wanted to make this
movie and so now it's been green lit it
netflix it's called rebel moon
um let me see the story's set in motion
when a peaceful colony in
it's a quick question can now can just
anyone make a star wars movie if you
don't need disney's permission you just
be like hey netflix what about vader
rocks they're like yeah come on
rebel moon did he have to change
anything
well i mean i'm sure there's no
skywalkers in it
um but you know the the whole idea like
rebel moon like how do we know this is
not star wars what's the main
character's name
and he's like uh bill
star walker
[Laughter]
i like this what does this bill cloud
look her into
it's got some droids
oh [ __ ] bathman's in because he knows
a [ __ ] thing or two about star wars
jc what about this
doesn't it has robots not droids droids
is
uh copyright errors trademarked by
lucasfilm
i know a thing or two about trademarks
and lucasfilm
yeah he does that's right jc who runs a
bar
in hollywood that has nothing to do with
star wars whatsoever
um uh go on mark um
the story is set in motion when a
peaceful colony on the edge of the
galaxy is threatened by the armies of a
tyrannical regent
named belisarius desperate people
dispatch a young woman with a mysterious
past
to seek out warriors from neighboring
planets to help them make a stand
so star wars it's like it's
seven samurai plus star wars plus
you know some old western um which is
ultimately what star wars is which is
sam it's secure course iowa plus space
um all right i mean who's doing it
netflix
um and ye old zach g snyder um he
uh he seems to have found a welcome home
at netflix which is a good friend
because warner brothers apparently
got to be you know they were like
there's the door [ __ ] go
so never come in here and maybe we'll
make all your dreams come true you want
to make a star wars movie
come on in any [ __ ] one pretty hot
good for him
yeah i mean i was i was hoping it would
be like a star wars zombie movie because
that would be [ __ ] badass
but that's true if he's playing all his
strengths he's like it's like star wars
but everybody's dead
especially if it's on netflix i it's you
know like we say in our house
like if it's on netflix it's free and
then i point out like no we pay for this
and uh then we move on what's the next
story my friend um
it's a thing that i think broke probably
about a week ago but we never got a
chance to talk about it
okay but um hbo
has decided they did not want to make a
second season of lovecraft country
yeah we didn't talk about this that's
right uh i mean i think you and i talked
about it
like by a text but we didn't talk about
this on the show
i found this incredibly surprising
because i thought it got a lot of
attention
got like seemed to get awards attention
particularly around this time i've seen
a lot of billboards up in town
for your consideration i absolutely
loved it i thought it was [ __ ]
insanely well made insanely well acted
and they
ended in such a way that led lent to a
season two
so what happened um you know it's sort
of unclear like hbo's statement just
says
we'll not be moving forward with the
second season of lovecraft country we're
grateful for the
dedication uh of the cast and crew and
to miesha green
uh the showrunner creator who crafted
this groundbreaking series
um the ratings apparently were pretty on
par
with watchmen uh as well as the outsider
and perry mason and so perry mason is
getting a second season although with
new showrunners um but the outsider is
not coming back
so it feels like it was probably in that
space where
you know it was six to five and pick em
it could come back it couldn't come back
if the conditions were right it might
but it also seemed as if you know misha
green had been at work on the second
season like
she apparently had crafted out a couple
of scripts she had a whole bible she she
teased it online she said we wish we
could have brought you lovecraft country
supremacy which was set in a whole
different alternate history of
the united states and she tweeted out a
map that had you know sort of
three different schisms of of the
country
so it's kind of unclear precisely what
happened
um other than we know we're not going to
get to see this
he's a bummer i really enjoyed it that
was a fun ride and creative as [ __ ] and
whatnot
you were there for the beginning of it
and then you kind of felt like i tapered
it a bit
you know i i loved the first episode um
and i think like the fourth episode um
you know it had its
it had its bobs and weaves it had
something downs but i thought that it
was incredibly brave and smart
um you know and and occasionally
brilliant
and i would have liked to see more
because you know there's there's the
world in which we all love shows that
didn't get great
until season two or three um there's a
lot of pressure on tv
at this point to come out of the gate
firing um and this did
but it you know there there was a there
was a sort of consistency that could
have been brought to bear
if it had been given another season
which would have done it wonders for me
it's a bummer man yeah what other news
you got
um matt damon i found this kind of cute
matt damon is in cannes
premiering his stillwater movie yeah
yeah um and he revealed i've seen the
trailer he mutters in it a lot
there's a lot of gaming for my daughter
i'm here for my daughter
like he's got that going on so it looks
pretty good yeah
um but he uh he revealed that at one
point he turned down
starring in avatar um
despite james cameron apparently
offering him a chunk of the film's
profits
and that's a movie that would have gone
on to gross uh about 2.8 billion dollars
what's the highest grossing film of all
time until end game and then the crown
went back to them recently i believe
yeah his quote was i was offered a
little movie called avatar james cameron
offered me 10
of it he recalled i will go down in
history you will never meet an actor who
turned down
more money no like why'd you turn it
down he's like ben
said i should
holy [ __ ] really i didn't know that yeah
i wonder he didn't say why he said no
he uh he said that he couldn't do the
movie because he was shooting the jason
bourne movies
and he took the moral decision to not
leave the franchise in the lurch
well morality pays it does
[ __ ] like keep 10 of avatar give me
10 of 1 of avatar
who's the [ __ ] world man that's crazy
um man oh man i know when
we were kids they offered him
daredevil first he passed for a similar
reason because he loved the character
but he's like i'm already committed to
this
and then they went to ben and uh you
know as we know ben played [ __ ] care
to him but
yeah i mean he passes on stuff mercy
not [ __ ] passed on my [ __ ] but
like
he does pass some things and not because
he's like this is beneath me
generally he's passing because he's
doing nine other things at the same time
but the avatar wow what a that's that's
something to carry around with you for
the rest of your life man you're like
could have been a billionaire
yes i wasn't born yeah he shared this
thing that he was apparently working
with john krasinski on something
and krasinski said uh nothing would be
different in your life if you had done
avatar except you and me were having
this
you and me would be having this
conversation in space
that's a good dude um all right what
else we got what other news
um now were you clearly there's there's
a love in your heart for
1980s animation yeah were you a fan of
silver hawks i'm familiar with it i
watched it um
i got to be careful here uh because i've
talked about being a fan of masters of
the universe and people were like you
weren't a [ __ ] fan you got the dates
wrong and [ __ ]
um let me let me clarify what i call
fandom and you tell me whether
or not i'm wrong uh i watched every
episode of
uh he-man in the masters universe when
it was happening in 1983
i was aged out for it i was about to be
13 years old
so you know you remember there wasn't a
lot of cable and there wasn't
a lot of [ __ ] no internet whatsoever
so you just kind of watched everything
that was on
so after school i'd come home he-man in
the master's universe ron
i watched every episode i would hate
watch most of it because i was like this
show is for babies man why won't they
[ __ ] stab
each other and [ __ ] every time i watch
the show i'd be like he's so metal this
guy's a living [ __ ] skeleton and they
won't stab
each other one day someone should make
them stab each other and that's what we
did with revelation
i watched every episode of that show
then there are people who are like
you're not a fan of the show you said
you [ __ ] hate watching as a kid and
[ __ ] i was like well
i literally watched every episode of
that show in real time
over and over again and stuff if you
watch something over and over again even
if you're [ __ ] picking fun at it and
[ __ ]
you are a [ __ ] fan man so
that being said no i didn't care for
silverhawk
though but it was not part of my world
yes silverhawks was a classic animated
tv show but developed by rank and bass
uh 1986 65 episodes the concept was the
team of 29th century heroes with metal
bodies and wings
who were tasked to stop an organized
crime ring and protect the citizens of
the galaxy of limbo
um and i remember that being a kid
because i was catholic and limbo was
like
you know there's a place between heaven
and hell where you could go
that's like not heaven or hell where
like if you die
and you've done some [ __ ] but not really
bad [ __ ] you could live there for like a
hundred thousand years before you get to
go to heaven you will eventually go to
heaven
but you just gotta wait a little longer
it's like earth two kind of thing
i remember that from the cartoon i
remember being like oh limbo we have
that and [ __ ] but that was my
only crossover with silverhawks it's
coming back isn't it
it is then the nacelle company which
produces disney pluses behind the
attraction
the movies that made us and the toys
that made us and that's right
brian nesell who runs that company made
the toys that made us which is an
amazing [ __ ] show
he is also responsible for a company
called comedy dynamics
and they made my stand up special uh
asylum but deadly that i was shooting
when i [ __ ] nearly died so
brian micelle was on set when i nearly
died
and that night i was supposed to do two
shows right you're supposed to
shoot two comedy shows and you blend
them in into one take all the best bits
and it becomes one show
so after the first show like you know
[ __ ] i was like i don't feel well and
i've told that story a zillion times
when they put me into the chair going
into the ambulance brian marcel who's
like well aware of the situation [ __ ]
but he's very funny
he comes over just before i leave he
goes so we're not doing the second show
then
like you know look at the toys that made
us that's his absolute sensibility
but he's now moving into animation with
this that's crazy
indeed um so so apparently the 80s
and animation is back in a big bad way
and i'm i would be surprised
if you know massive universe revelation
is not some kind of a lightning rod for
all of this
the idea that people can come back
rejuvenate refresh
breathe new life into an old thing and
uh
and get lots of attention and and
hopefully lots of acclaim
because it's really good um that's what
hollywood does
like worked over there let's try it over
here and we're guilty of the same
[ __ ] thing like going into the
writer's room on master of the universe
my thing was like let's do what marvel
does man
like basically doing a good job let's
just [ __ ] take the stories from your
childhood
and treat them all like their [ __ ]
bible truth and whatnot
and then just add the adults of it all
like hey they could actually get stabbed
like that's the only difference
uh between he-man and the massive
universe and and
our masters of the universe it's like we
treated it like
this is the next episode but in this
episode they could all stab each other
and [ __ ]
so i mean that's a formulaic you do for
[ __ ] anything that you grew up
watching
as a child with the exception of like
deviant goliath and rocky and bullwinkle
of truth
it's not like it's rocky and bullwinkle
but now they can stab each other
[ __ ] if you told me we could do
davey and goliath where they just stab
each other over and over again
but baby it's a sin he's like shut up
dog talks no more you want to be a
latter day saint punk
[Laughter]
um all right good for brian to sell man
i hope he makes a lot of cartoons i'm
gonna get in touch with that guy and be
like look if you're making cartoons man
i watched a lot of cartoons in the 80s
man let me tell them
pick a card any card i can do this yeah
man holy [ __ ]
did you do dragons that's the one i
would really like to do i watched that
cartoon
not the game i never played the [ __ ]
game i wasn't creative enough also
didn't have friends
but i watched uh the cartoon dungeon
dragons and [ __ ] loved it so if
somebody was like
do that again i'd be like i [ __ ] do
that in a heartbeat man
but uh yeah it seems like the 80s are
coming back in a big bad way
cartoon style but that all seems to be
like yeah tip your hat to marvel star
wars
as well star wars brought our childhood
back before anybody else probably right
um yeah i think so but also you know
shira
did a great job of like finding a thing
that was
old and reinventing it and invigorating
and bringing it back to a new audience
very very true um oh man is in what do
you got to add to the present
also the netflix voltron show which was
like five years seven seasons was
fantastic and that was also like you i
know you were a big fan that was also
taking what everybody knew
and then just extending it it wasn't
like everything you knew about voltron
was wrong he's a [ __ ] frog this time
it was literally just like all that [ __ ]
happened and then the next day
voltron took a [ __ ] like it just kept
going right no it was
kind of like uh taking the
the foundation of voltron and then
building a new
story off of it that was awesome though
yeah and i think if we have to trace it
all back it's probably a bit
transformers like we're going to make
this
gigantic blockbuster movie based on a
cartoon
from the 80s which was based on a toy
line and then there's never been
a time where we haven't had a new
version of transformers you know
animated live action whatever it is but
they've been they've done a fantastic
job
quality notwithstanding of keeping
transformers alive
[Music]
um fair enough we're all living in
michael bay's [ __ ] world
michael bay simulation ladies and
gentlemen the michael banaverse
[ __ ] flags and [ __ ] like that what
else we got mark what other news wither
the news mark
um two more stories um one is a little
light and celebratory the other one is
uh less so
um the first is today this very day
on july 10th is the 40th anniversary of
john carpenter's escape from new york
oh [ __ ] a man a classic an absolute
classic
40 years old 40 years old
that tracks i guess i would have seen it
when i was like 10 and i just kind of
leave in fifth grade wow yeah 1981
and i i i love that movie and i think i
love the first 10 minutes of it
40 years old 40 years old so it came out
the same year as raiders of the lost ark
about 40 or 45 this year that was 40
this year
they're both 40 years old i never in a
million years a gun in my head somebody
was like
[ __ ] big trouble little trying to
come out the same time as the lost
target but like i don't [ __ ] know
they blow my brains out and [ __ ] but
i wouldn't i wouldn't put those two
thank you i wouldn't put those two
together man
yeah no uh i love the first 10 minutes
of escape from new york
i think more than i like from new york
did i just say big trouble
big trouble i was i was going to
steamroll over it jesus is wrong mark i
was
so it's the 40th anniversary of escape
from new york all right
that makes a lot of sense that tracks
oh that's delicious obviously i'd run
out of drink and thankfully ernie castle
keeper and the o'donnell
um what else um and this this was the
big one this is the
um bidding farewell to richard donner
who passed away monday of this week at
91 years old that's right ladies and
gentlemen we lost a great man give it up
to the great richard donner
a good guy a good human being by all uh
reports and stuff like that but
obviously a brilliant [ __ ] filmmaker
um
without him we don't have the modern day
superhero movie we're still
working off the formula that he
established you know with
uh superman back in the 70s yeah i mean
superman
goonies the luther weapons series he was
a producer
on the original x-men movies um all the
x-men movies that
for them lady hawk yep and
like the list goes on he's the dude that
directed the episode of the twilight
zone with
william shatner he's like there's a man
on the wing of this plane like that's
how far
the guy goes back the omen yeah
i got to meet with them was it two years
ago
they're trying to make a show over uh
well they were trying i'm
probably still trying i'm out of it at
this point but they were trying to make
a show
maybe at hbo max or no i think it was
for some reason i think it was apple
but it would have made more sense at hbo
max
the idea was uh to do uh
a tv show a dramatization of the making
of superman because it was a story that
was fraught with
you know uh so many pitfalls and whatnot
it was a miracle the movie came to
happen
uh at all and a miracle that it turned
into the movie that it was they're
dealing with like technology that didn't
exist
and [ __ ] like that and you know uh wacky
fair producers
and a young director a studio that was
not quite the studio it is today
so you know you can get a lot out of it
and they're very there's been articles
written about it and documentaries and
there's some funny material and [ __ ] so
they're talking about
turning that into a series and so they
were like uh
richard donner wants to meet with people
who could potentially
write the show and and uh liz destro
who's our producer on j and samba reboot
and also
a producer on clerk's three if we ever
get make it one day
oh my god i would love to do that i said
but the very least i would love to just
meet [ __ ] dick donner and she's like
go talk to dick donner about the show
i'll bring you in so i got to meet
with richard donner um at his offices
and he was
90 at that point i think he passed away
it was about 91
yeah so he had just like hit 90 or
something like that
and so naturally he moved like a 90 year
old man with i would say
slower than most people but not like
super slow we were like this guy's got
one foot in the grave
he was still pretty damn surprised for a
90 year old but more than that
this sharp is a [ __ ] tack and what a
[ __ ] storyteller
what a rack and tour man like the dude
was a wonderful storyteller
uh with his craft right and filmed
entertainment but just
a dude sitting in a room talking like
you just sat there
listening to him he just had that voice
and the ability
to spin a [ __ ] yarn man and like it
served him well in his craft
but just in a room with a dude i found
him incredibly
impressive endearing as [ __ ] and whatnot
like just
you know he's dropping like he'll be
talking about things he's like and then
marlin
and you're like marlon brando like he
was around
for movie history but like ev you know
the way i sit around tell stories and
[ __ ]
take that but like make it about [ __ ]
you care about you know what i'm saying
instead of like
i tell you my yoga hoser story here's a
[ __ ] who could tell you like why
the kid on the omen was so [ __ ]
creepy and [ __ ]
and it's a funny charming [ __ ] story
so we were sitting there like listening
to him for like
hours as he went on and you know me i
like to [ __ ] talk and shut people up
and [ __ ] but i was just so happy
to hear the dude talk and you know i the
job didn't wind up coming together if i
could go but happened i don't know where
the project is at this point and [ __ ]
but i considered myself even then i was
like that was [ __ ] cool i was lucky
to have been
able to hang out with uh richard dunn
when i heard the news the other day i
was like oh my god thank god i did get
to like see that guy
before he left this world because i
remember talking to him in the office
and being like
i i and this is going to sound [ __ ]
weird and i don't want to scare you and
[ __ ]
but i was like i try to live my entire
life
like like the last 10 minutes of
scrooged
you know like i love that bill murray
[ __ ] monologue and stuff
and i was like i love the feeling when i
watched that movie
and then the credits would roll and i'd
forget the next day about that [ __ ]
like
everything he spoke about and [ __ ] and
how it can easily be kind of
enacted in my own life i was like so
i've for the last 10 15 years of my life
like i figured out what i've been going
for all this time and i think that it's
me trying to [ __ ] live my entire life
the way frank cross felt at the end of
scrooge
and he was just excuse me he goes kevin
i've heard a lot of [ __ ] in this
business
he's called but that was the prettiest
wonderful dude man who's like work i've
been consuming since i was a kid i
remember going to see
superman in the movie theater i remember
seeing with my family once in new jersey
and then once again
in kansas city when we were taking like
a train trip and whatnot
he was one of the first director names i
knew after george lucas and steven
spielberg
there was richard donner so it well you
know i'm not like i didn't
lose sleep over it or or cry because i
didn't know the man that well but like i
loved his not just his work but who he
seemed to be from afar and i was so
delighted to find out
he was exactly who he seemed to be from
afar when i got to hang out with him
also had all the confidence of a 90 year
old man something that i look forward to
in my own 50
51 in augustanship but like this is how
[ __ ] comfy was this just ripping this
[ __ ] story man telling this [ __ ]
story and it's amazing
and the middle of it ripped one of the
meanest parts i've ever heard in my life
and he goes like that's for later anyway
anyway
he was he was absolute [ __ ] gold at
least for that [ __ ] day
your thoughts the great dick donald um
you know he he he defined a lot of
the 80s for me you know and the 90s for
me i mean
between from from lady hawk and all the
lethal weapons and goonies and
you know he he and he was not going to
say that he was a workman because that's
wrong but he's a dude who started in tv
in the 50s
yeah and just he was a director he was a
shooter he got what do you got this week
wanted dead or alive sure streets his
name cisco sure twilight zone sure i can
do anything
and it felt like that when he was making
movies like i can do whatever you got
superman sure goonies yeah for me to
produce the lost boys you got it
you know like he was just a guy who
could make anything work
and i always appreciated that and yeah
like the stories about him and his
generosity and his kindness
have all kind of began to flood out over
the last you know week or so
and my favorite of them was from jeff
cohen who played chunk
in goonies oh he said when my
acting career started to peter out i
still love show business and dick let me
be a production assistant for him
i worked for my warner brothers when i
was applying to college i said hey dick
can you write me a letter of
recommendation for college
he said sure kid apparently he called
everybody kid if you were seven years
old he called your kid if you're 50 he
calls your kid
so he asked me to put some notes
together to give him an indication of
what he should say and the note to him i
told him about my life and some of the
struggles i went through as a kid
my father not being there and other
issues that i dealt with and he called
me on the phone and instead of merely
writing a letter of recommendation to
college he told me that he and lauren
had read my letter and they were going
to pay for my college
i was absolutely flabbergasted i was
shocked i had to sit down because for me
paying for college was going to be a
problem
that changed my life not only
economically but it showed that dick and
lauren believed in me
they thought that i could do something
they thought that i could make something
of myself that is dick donner being kind
being empathetic and not because he
wanted anything in return
[ __ ] beautiful man and that came from
chunk chuck jeff cohen trump loves sloth
that chunk
that trump can you go on he's got a big
job i remember reading something he's a
lawyer now i think he's an entertainment
lawyer
that's some powerful [ __ ] man um number
one how beautiful
of the donners to do that number two uh
if you're out there and you're like hey
i've worked for kevin smith as an actor
i won't pay for your colleagues never
made that lethal weapon
money kid so you know i could send you
to college but that's so righteous what
a good dude
yeah um well uh you know we pour one out
for the great richard donner it's true
loss
for our community when i was meeting
with him um he was talking about putting
together the next
lethal weapon movie that's going to
happen he goes yeah we're doing it on
the sly and [ __ ]
so i don't know where that project lies
at this point if they got deep into it
or anything like that
but i'd heard rumors around town that
there was it was still
kind of happening um but i can't imagine
it happening now without him he seemed
to be
the linchpin of all those productions
like whenever they show behind the
scenes stuff
everyone just adored the guy so i can't
i go on without him
plus mel gibson
yeah um is that the end is that the end
of our news
that is the end of the news my friends
i have two news stories uh one just
because mark mentioned it a little bit
earlier when we were talking about the
80s
uh transformer seven is
coming out and they released a title
which was
rise of the beasts which means they're
going to be doing the beast wars
version of transformers um
and then the other thing that we missed
which i've been getting harassed and
chat about
star wars visions did you guys see the
little star wars visions oh i did
that what is it so visions
is i imagine similar to marvel what if
but within star wars and they took
uh kind of like a manga style
animation and they went out to all these
different animation houses and said
tell a star wars story that means
something to you and so
i guess there was a an anime convention
that they released this little like
three minute
taste where you got to see behind the
scenes and they listed all the different
animation companies doing it and it
looks really really
cool uh almost like animatrix
ish but with star wars um
and uh one of the guys in chat ben
bamboo was saying
how cool would it be if if visions
does well it's not canon it's just
stories about star wars
if george went in and did an animated
version of his seven eight and nine so
we could all see it
i was like let's let's get that
change.org petition going
yeah really yeah who came up with this
idea ben bamboo
ben bamboo in the chat he's one of our
regulars does he run disney
unfortunately not damn bamboo you better
get running disney you're gonna make a
cool suggestion like that
oh go ahead i was just gonna say the
vision stuff looks really cool and it
looks like a really
kind of far cry from anything we've seen
in star wars before
um so i i i'm i'm really looking forward
to it
it feels like like a proved fan fiction
in a kind of beautiful way which is
hey you people who are really talented
make whatever version of star wars you
want
you know and we'll pay for it and we'll
put it on our channel like that
i love that idea that that these stories
this world is strong enough to support
these sort of wild interpretations of it
um
and i don't know anybody else i mean
star trek could maybe support that kind
of
um you know monkeying with it
maybe maybe the mcu can you know it'd be
it'd be great
to just let people run wild go for it do
what you want to do
um look if they're ever gonna reach out
to me i got a cool idea about [ __ ]
death star contractors that i could do
for him but
all right man [ __ ] mark went out and
hunted for all the news we thought he
gave it to you all jc gave you a little
bit of the end just the tip but mark
gave you the full [ __ ] to the balls
news give it up for mark bernard ladies
and gentlemen
all right kids that brings us to the
part of the show that everyone [ __ ]
loves the interactive part of the show
the second news the second ad oh [ __ ]
i mean yes we got it ladies and
gentlemen and we're so lucky to have
that [ __ ] sponsor
the second half uh the ending half this
back half
of the fat man beyond uh we're proud
to have as our sponsor keeps ladies and
gentlemen mark tell them about keeps
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time
they're 35
and i think two of the men on this
podcast can also
speak to that um there are only two fda
approved
medications that can prevent it and
keeps offers both simple stress-free way
to keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications deliver straight to your
door
every three months low-cost the
treatments are like 10 bucks a month
that's where they start anyway and keeps
offers genetic yeah
generic versions discrete packaging
proven results
prevention is key change
yes just
prevention is key treatments can take up
to four to six months
to see results so act fast and if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss
go to k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fat man
to receive your first month of treatment
for free
and then for some reason like we must be
helping them move some keeps products
man because they keep jumping
on with us uh a lot of people in our
audience apparently want to keep their
hair man that's the smart play you could
do that
with the good folks it keeps that
address again mark k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man get your first
month
for free we thank the good folks at
keeps.com
uh for being sponsors of fat man beyond
give it up for the folks at keeps.com
ladies and gentlemen
keeps is your bridge to the q and a
portion of the show ladies and gentlemen
everyone's favorite portion of the show
uh banff man jump in and tell me how are
we doing this
[ __ ] i didn't say jump in like that i
got a live audience here i feel like
i should be pulling questions from the
live audience no
um i've i've got some questions here i
think
uh we should we should get at least one
live
one live i said at least
ooh to the internet and [ __ ] i think
that ratio
i think we could do three live and one
internet
there you go there's a man who's [ __ ]
thinking mark you now the producer of
the show
but now you're gonna have the same
problem i always used to have
which you have to pick so now
everybody's gonna be mad at you because
i'm in los angeles and so they can't be
mad at me because i can't see them
that's an excellent point man so jc
ain't gonna get blamed but i might be
able to handle this
uh do we still have another comic book
men still in the house
is there a comic book man in the house
is ming still here
did ming just say no
whatever um uh
okay yeah we don't have [ __ ] ming in
the room so that's i was gonna make ming
do it and [ __ ] like that
and since he was on comic book men have
been relevant to the conversation
but ming's not here so instead ladies
and gentlemen castle keeper ernie
o'donnell
let's bring him up here ernie come on up
here real quick give it up for ernie
o'donnell ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much ernie built smod
castle here man how's it going so far
sir
very good i love it you're a happy
camper damn skippy buddy
ernie's having a blast like i i'm i'm
like a kid man this is crazy he really
is kids he's walking around like he's
[ __ ] robert de niro and casino it's
amazing
he's got the whole [ __ ] place wired
and [ __ ] i feel like i'm sure he's gotta
give me a smiley castle suit
done and done we will get something real
smooth um okay we're gonna let you
pick the people in the audience that way
people get mad they get mad at you
oh i can take it we can uh let's go uh
like we can turn the lights on so we can
see people
you want me to run back and turn the
lights on too i do it all buddy oh my
god that's right i will do it he's
literally the only and he's doing it too
ernie's the one-man operation that keeps
spodcastle running give it up for ernie
man
bamf i feel like i'm watching the
the alternate version of me like i feel
like i'm in the loki show now like i'll
turn on the lights i'll do the questions
this is your variant right here this is
my variant
um okay uh we'll turn it over to you i'm
going to let you pick
what's mad what'd you see oh there's a
bug he's enjoying the show man don't
don't
what the [ __ ] oh my god that's such bad
[ __ ] karma he's not dead
all right then put him outside no i'm
gonna put in my pocket
that [ __ ] is sitting on the
table he's like you know what i'm going
to learn to trust humans
he's like [ __ ] is kevin smith
[ __ ] yeah just like everybody
else uh you know what
it's your place if you want to kill bugs
you get to kill bugs or
uh you've earned that [ __ ] right as
you can see ernie's wearing a smog
castle t-shirt
show it off kids uh if you're here
in the uh audience you want one of these
fine smog castle t-shirts
here at smod castle in order to buy
things and [ __ ] we don't have a register
here and stuff
we send people right down the end of the
building to quick stop so people are
buying their drinks and food at quick
stop
that's where we're selling the smog
castle shirts too so if you want one
go grab one that'll make smog castle
keeper ernie
thank you very much that being said
raise your hands if you want to ask a
question
ernie pick i'ma close my eyes hmm
yeah take the time go ahead just [ __ ]
pick a hand
you know what yes i have to say i like
the guys this weekend
does that say weekend for the sun stand
up stand up young camper come here and
here
bring him up because we can keep him on
camera
don't kill no bugs face the audience
what is your name young camper wait spin
that spin that [ __ ] you get by kevin
i don't need to be
and we'll give it up for jason he's
going to ask a question
hi jason um okay jason uh question for
me and mark fire away
um in the uh as jc said uh
variants this is weird here sit here
next to me
that way you're not like looking back
over your shoulder and [ __ ] like that
have a seat
and this mic's not hooked up so just i'm
still gonna be here here we go all right
this mic was more about decor than
anything else
um okay ask the question um what loki
variance would
you and mark be interested in seeing and
what variants of each other would you
like to see you have to pick for each
other not pick your own
[ __ ] good question give it up for
them man that's sweet
what chem variant would i like to see
okay what loki variants would i like to
see
um let me see we've seen
kid loki uh we've seen
jack kirby looking loki we've seen
worthy loki um we've seen
lady loki you've seen
uh mayor loki mariloki or
president loki i mean just for my own
preferences i'd love to see a silent
loki
that'd be good for my brand mark you i
would like to see the loki that does not
whip his hair back every 15 [ __ ]
minutes
he does that man he's like he's always
[ __ ] whipping this air back and forth
and [ __ ]
he's got that head of hair i would do
the same [ __ ] thing
keeps.com
keeps.com [ __ ] audience saved our ass
on that one well done
uh what about our variants what variant
of kevin smith would i like to see
um don't say naked variant
i mean we're all naked under our clothes
kevin excellent
uh i would like to see disco kevin smith
what kind disco disco kev
1970's kip bell bottoms afro [ __ ]
groovy kev
um [ __ ] all right [ __ ] i hadn't seen
that answer coming
i but better than naked kevin smith
oh we'll get you there it's disco kevin
naked kevin is not far away
starts on the dance floor and then we
take our clothes off um
my variant for mark
would be
bad writer mark
so whenever i talked to him he was just
like oh
what if like the one guy had said to the
other guy
who was the guy who has said that thing
to the guy
what if he was like hey guy don't be
like that guy
mark every every yeah basically what if
mark was jason beers
that's right mark bernard's variant is
jason news
writer variant mark would be my my
character
i would like that action figure
he's got scripts in his hand and [ __ ]
um excellent question give it up for him
ladies and gentlemen welcome
oh we have been joined by
i would love to see the drunk
variant of kevin and the stoner variant
of mark
there's a guy who knows our show well
[ __ ] done man
we've seen the drunk variants of mark
that's for sure
you've got skywalker in the house he
starts skywalking
um the drunk version of me is like i'm
i'm i'm
very sentimental you know how i wear my
heart on my [ __ ] sleeve anyway
drunk me is just like my [ __ ] love
all of us man
so it would get irritating very quick
that would be a variant you'd want
stabbed or what do they call it pruned
there you go um excellent question give
it up for him one more time
can i get a picture now and abuse the
situation
we'll do that afterwards um all right
who's the next question ern
i think i got him come on some [ __ ]
it's dj dj come on up and ask a question
face that camera so people can see it
sit here in this chair
ernie's gonna be your human mic stand
is there not a mic right next to you kev
it was only for show
oh that's adorable ornamentation not for
[ __ ]
go ahead all right so you guys have a
show coming out this month that
according to the internet may or may not
happen
in it um
and i know you said before you know you
don't want to touch the marvel stuff you
don't want just the star wars stuff but
for both of you working on this
does it make you want to play with
someone else's toy so to speak
more or less and if so i know you just
said duns and dragons morgan mark
is there something else from back in the
day you'd want to grab a hold of him put
your spin on
what a great question that may or may
not include you man
um based on the experience i had on
masters
um like it did make me go like oh [ __ ]
it's fun playing with somebody else's
toys
i still feel there's some toys that
should be placed out of my reach because
i don't think i'd be good at playing
with him and stuff so it doesn't make me
more confident in terms of like
now i can [ __ ] take on marvel and
[ __ ] like that but it did make me feel
like
i like going into it i was like i'm
pretty sure i can pull this off like i
think i could be
incredibly reverent while like taking
the story forward and stuff
so it's very case-by-case basis but this
first case
so far so good where i felt like oh my
god i legit had fun doing it
going into it i was like well this will
be an interesting exercise
and coming out of it i'm like that's one
of my five favorite things i've ever
done
so i could definitely get my head around
doing again but not
at expert level or something like that
i'm still content to just watch
marvel movies i don't and tv shows and
[ __ ] like that i don't need to be
involved with those because as i've
learned on masters
you can have as much fun as you [ __ ]
want you could do as great a job as you
possibly can and that's not just you
that's all the people involved all the
writers powerhouse
[ __ ] netflix mattel television and at
the end of the day
like what you don't think about even
though we thought our whole project
about
what the fans would think like soul
things predicated on the history of the
characters and stuff
like we could not have predicted that
there's a portion of the audience that's
just like well we're mad and stuff or we
feel like we've been lied to or whatever
the [ __ ]
all that planning and like still
couldn't see that coming so there's a
portion of me that's like okay
the masters of the universe audience
very big they sold billions of dollars
of toys in the 80s and stuff but
it's coming back so right now there's
definitely vocal people about it and
stuff but its audience isn't as big as
say the marvel
movies taking on one of those marvel
movies you're not only [ __ ] like
taking on the sicipian task of trying to
make just a good movie that's going to
satisfy the high bar the audience is
accustomed to
you then also have to take on the
audience rage if you drop the ball
in their perception so the little taste
of the rage that i've got from working
on masters in the universe
is more than enough for me to be like i
will just watch marvel for my entire
[ __ ] life
because i couldn't i don't think i can
handle it like that might that many
people
being upset that you didn't do what they
thought you were going to do or
something like that like earlier i
talked about like man i thought [ __ ]
taskmaster was gonna be this
but what they did i actually liked and
[ __ ] um
i have you know there's a lot of love
don't get me wrong 99 [ __ ] percent of
the people talking about the show
loving what they see and [ __ ] like that
but that one percent like
they're they're mad and they're gonna
stay mad doesn't matter i think they'll
watch the show
and even if it's not what they think it
is i think they'll still kind of stay
mad
and knowing what a soft boy i am my
mother told me my whole life you're too
soft don't talk to others and [ __ ]
they'll hurt your feelings
knowing that i shouldn't have gone into
the arts but i [ __ ] did and i know my
threshold
like having dealt with this for like a
month or so on masters universe
i would never want to up it up up the
ante and be like let me take on some
[ __ ] that people
everywhere [ __ ] care about or
something like that um
sooner or later i think masters will get
so popular that they'll be like we'll
take this out of your hands now
but right now like i get to be in the
[ __ ] cappard seat and it's been
absolutely wonderful but it doesn't
fill me with overconfidence where i'm
like i'm ready to take on the big boys i
still
it happens get the [ __ ] out
did you set your google maps to get to
the bathroom
um anyway that's my long story short
answer
mark yours um i i think you know i can't
speak for you kev
because that would be futile i don't
have the words um
but the experience on masters was
very much where everybody involved saw
the same show
you know mattel knew what they wanted
netflix knew what they wanted
you knew what you wanted it was all the
same thing and i think when you're
working with legacy
ip like that and you're working with a
with a franchise like that
everybody involved needs to see the same
show and so that's what marvel does
incredibly well where everybody's seeing
the show that
feige or the movie that feige wants to
tell but there's other
giant franchises where it's harder to
make everybody
get on the same page so my desire
to play in other sort of sandboxes
is entirely and directly related to how
many people
have their fingers in the pie and can
those people all see the same pie we're
trying to bake
and not looking for blueberry and apple
and cherry and
we end up with some [ __ ] up turducken
that nobody wants to eat
um so i but my gut like there's a piece
of me
i don't know if anybody else remembers
this show i i have a fondness for it
probably based entirely on the opening
sequence
but galaxy rangers was the show back in
like
82 83 84 um probably also based on a set
of toys that i never played with
but i just loved the you know it was it
was
firefly before we had firefly it's a
space western where they got like robot
horses and one dude is clearly the
wolverine of the team that's got this
arm that lights up and it's [ __ ]
metal and the other dude's got a
[ __ ] cannon and the other guy's got
magic [ __ ] six shooters and like it's
it was badass to like 13 year old me
and i feel like to get to play in that
universe with those characters would
just be fun
i just want to have fun and that feels
like it would let you have fun like the
same way we got to have fun on masters
so more fun all the time i agree
give it up that's a great answer great
question give it up to dj give it up for
monday
thank you thank you
all right third question from the
audience earn this is a real sophie's
choice is the last one you get to pick
what's it gonna be i'm going deep oh
i was gonna touch it but i'll leave it
right there come on brother
come on up oh my god you're like doing
it like let's make a deal you're running
through the aisles and [ __ ] like that
next people will be wearing this game
let's see if we're the slowest here have
a set
uh what's your name young camper derek
everyone give it up for derek he's going
to ask a question
now hold on derek before we get started
with the question somebody just went
into the bathroom at smod castle
the bathroom at smog castle is right
next to the stage let's listen and hear
them piss
oh but what if it's not piss good point
let's move on
okay ask your question okay quick
anecdote yeah um did you guys ever hear
the theory
that michael keaton's batman sold his
life rights
and that's when we got batman forever
and batman
so that's the in in-canon universe of
why the total shift was so radical
so this theory the thesis then states
that
batman and batman returns are real
but bruce wayne sold this story to be
made for a movie and the movie
is batman forever and batman and robin
yes i totally [ __ ] buy that theory
man
right that's a real that's a really good
one yeah that would explain a thing or
two about it
the tonal ship well done i buy that i
co-signed that
i'm gonna believe in that as much as i
believed and i knew who task master was
what do you got okay so um
my grandfather was my alfred he passed
away that same day
i read tom king's hold on one second
don't roll over that that's some of the
most beautiful writing i've ever heard
on this show
my grandfather was my alfred yep that is
so evocative
instantly i had a [ __ ] image of your
relationship that's [ __ ] beautiful do
you write
no you
mark you're a good writer you like that
i just want to know if he's also a
batman
you haven't seen me and batman at the
same place at the same time that's true
um all right keep going okay so i that
night
after everything settled i read uh tom
king's issue
of his batman run yes and it was
when batman was intoxicated with this
venom
scarecrow toxin thing yeah and he had
this lifelike vivid
image of alfred and he had to say
goodbye to him
yes it's from his memory because
alfred's dead in that comic
run right now yes so the question is
um has a comic book ever gotten you guys
through a traumatic experience
or helped you cope with something that
day
later on or something like that um hands
down
absolutely what a great question give it
up great question ladies and gentlemen
and an even better theory that makes
[ __ ] batman forever and batman and
robin watchable again where it's like oh
yeah this is the movie they made about
him and even batman was bad in real life
um okay yes uh there are comic book
panels imagery
pages story lines uh that have
profoundly affected
my life and i'm sure you know most
adults who aren't into this [ __ ]
would hear fellow adult say that and be
like you've lived a wasted life and i
believe the exact opposite i think i've
found things in art
that have enriched my life as a human
being in ways that
sometimes normal uh normalcy wouldn't
like some people can't say
things to you quite as beautiful as a
writer could put it you know what
nobody's ever said to me in my life
before or not said to me or said that
made me [ __ ] stop
ponder my grandfather was my outfit
something like that
you know you get that from somebody you
don't walk into [ __ ] wawa and you're
like i packed cigarettes and like my
grandfather was my outfit
you know you get that from the arts and
stuff and so arts
comic books big part of the arts and for
me very entertaining part of the arts i
love reading books don't get me wrong
but i love reading comics far more
they're shorter and they're more
visually interesting than a standard
book it's not to put people off books
and stuff
i'm not illiterate but i just [ __ ]
love graphics you know
obviously for years i've been talking
about comics
one comic book page and panel
particularly
has really shaped like the last i don't
know
15 years of my life probably since i
became like a fairly
serious stoner uh and that is uh i'm
gonna
i'm i'm gonna run the risk of the
internet being you're lying again
but it's page one of the dark knight
returns i could be wrong
maybe it's on page two but i'm i'm
pretty damn sure it's [ __ ] page one
um as previously mentioned there's a
stoner bear with me because sometimes
[ __ ]
[ __ ] slips but i'm pretty sure it's page
one on page one
bruce wayne in the book of course is uh
driving a [ __ ] race car
uh around the track and whatnot and he's
going at high speeds
and he's got people in his ear you know
ferris uh raceway track going like you
gotta
pull out you're gonna [ __ ] hurt
yourself get out you're crazy it's too
fast keep going
and everyone's alerting him to get out
of the [ __ ] car and you know
frank miller is very powerful internals
for bruce wayne kind of kick
off the story where he talks about like
if i i don't remember it exactly but if
i go into this
uncontrolled slide i'm going to be dead
within like 12 seconds of bla
bla and a blaze of fuel involved very
frank
miller s dialogue but the line that
profoundly [ __ ] affects me and still
kind of shapes decisions i make to this
day
is he has bruce wayne say after
setting up what will happen momentarily
how he's gonna crash this car
there's no way [ __ ] out of it and
stuff like that rather than read his
panic
the next line he writes for bruce wayne
is this would be a good
death and right then and there you're
like jesus christ
like this is a different [ __ ] main
character than you've ever dealt with
before because you're like this is meant
to be batman
and batman is talking about like death
and this would be a good death what the
[ __ ] is going on instantly
you're [ __ ] pulled into it in terms
of storytelling and then the very next
panel he says but not good enough and he
turns the wheel
and the entire [ __ ] story begins it
always struck me that like
if he's like this would be a good death
and it is
dark night ends on page one and it's all
[ __ ] over but because he makes the
decision to [ __ ] turn the wheel
knowing that like by heading this path
like
i'm gonna get what i've always wanted
because this character has searched his
entire life for a [ __ ] good death
my take on batman he's so [ __ ] grief
stricken he don't want to live in this
terrible [ __ ] world that killed his
parents as a boy but in order for him to
function and live in this [ __ ] world
that's the only way he can handle it by
dressing up like idiotically and beating
the [ __ ] out of [ __ ] chains snatchers
and muggers and stuff
it's really something kind of beautiful
about that and here we have the old
example of that guy
the guy who gave up on the the kind of
brief idealism of the childhood vow he
made over his dead parents like this
will never
[ __ ] happen to anybody else he's
passed that [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] seeing the table is tilted
the game is [ __ ] rigged man
it's all a [ __ ] joke and [ __ ] he's
been out of it for 10 [ __ ] years
why bother living what he's been looking
for his whole life
is a good [ __ ] death he never got it
at the hands of any of the [ __ ]
villains riddler catwoman joker penguin
whoever [ __ ] fought
and on page one of dark knight returns
he's like this would be a good
death and you feel the sense of like
this is what he's been looking for his
whole life
and just when like the one kid you might
give it up for the one person you might
understand
suicidal in this world where it's just
like [ __ ] how much you gonna
throw at this kid he lost his parents he
gets beat up by clowns all the [ __ ]
time like
everything in his room in his life is
bad and [ __ ] you would forgive him if he
was like this would be a good death and
[ __ ] i'm finally going for it
but there's just that little bit of
[ __ ] hope left in the kid
that watched his parents die where he's
like but not good enough
turns the wheel starts the whole [ __ ]
story
every decision in my life where i sit
there going like well this would be it
this is like what you wanted this is
everything you [ __ ] dreamed about and
[ __ ] this is the end
and then i'm usually like yeah but and i
[ __ ]
turned the wheel because of that book i
was like if you just
what happens if you turn the wheel like
you you know like i thought going into
[ __ ]
black widow i knew exactly who [ __ ]
taskmaster was
but they turned the wheel at the last
second and i was like oh [ __ ]
like i didn't see that coming sometimes
every time i don't give a [ __ ] man
it's always worth turning the wheel so
that panel means the [ __ ] world to me
i'm not trying to communicate that
like i'm i've been suicidal or anything
i [ __ ] love myself too much to ever
think about that sort of thing
but i'm a person filled with self-doubt
and [ __ ] like that
that page has been very very powerful
for me so i love that the other profound
page is not long a story but it's just
an
impactful image i guess it is kind of a
longer story
is uh in daredevil there's another frank
miller run
but it's dave mazzy kelly art and stuff
uh frank miller's run of daredevil
in uh born born again like one of the
greatest comic book stories ever
written where the kingpin disassembles
finds out that matt murdock is
daredevil and disassembles his life
without him knowing it and [ __ ] to try
to drive him crazy and before he can
finally break him and [ __ ] just
[ __ ] cruel [ __ ] the whole story gets
started because
karen page's ex-girlfriend sold his
secret
like she wound up as a junkie in another
country i think columbia or something
like that
and she to get a little horse or
something she was like matt murdock is
daredevil and that information
traveled all the way to the kingpin and
in the book frank miller's like everyone
who touched that information
died because kingpin is the only one who
wants to have that information to
himself and stuff
so because of karen page kind of selling
out that [ __ ] secret [ __ ]
it starts everything and matt murdock's
life is turned into literal [ __ ] hell
it's one of the greatest deconstructions
of the character of all time
he strips him not just his heroism but
his [ __ ] humanity and leaves him with
absolutely nothing that's how he wants
to destroy daredevil
so karen page simultaneously is trying
to make her way from where she was
lost and broken back to new york because
she's like matt will save me
matt will help me and stuff so she
finally gets to new york she's being
hunted down by this like killer [ __ ]
pimp that she's been traveling with this
drug dealer and [ __ ]
uh he's drawing down on her in an
alleyway he's gonna shoot her [ __ ] all
the things going [ __ ] dire
matt murdock and daredevil are [ __ ]
gone nowhere to be seen
con presumably kingpin has [ __ ]
broken him
there's karen paige in the alley and
she's a junkie and so she wants to fix
one last time she knows she's gonna die
at this dude's [ __ ] gun and [ __ ] and
so she's desperate to [ __ ] put the
knee i'm going to cry just talking about
this [ __ ]
she's somebody got a tissue yeah good
box of tissue she's desperate to get the
[ __ ] needle into her
arm and you see she's like you know the
beautiful voiceover he wrote for her
she's just
lost she's like there's nothing to
[ __ ] live for
and then all of a sudden there's this
[ __ ] panel where the billy club
comes out of nowhere and [ __ ] knocks
the needle out of her hand and arm
takes out the [ __ ] guy who is going
to shoot her
and there's a full page spread uh of
giant [ __ ] splash page
of uh matt murdock you know wearing like
a [ __ ]
oh if i remember correctly kind of like
a marty mcfly vest
type of jacket thing he's got full
growth of his beard and [ __ ] he's not
dressed like daredevil
at all and he's kneeling on the ground
and he is holding the look like the most
thankful human being
you've ever seen in your life and it's
not like oh the hero rescued the [ __ ]
girl again or some [ __ ] like that
this guy would be totally justified in
not
[ __ ] rescuing this person and this
person like [ __ ] knows it has no
expectations be rescued forgiven
anything like that and this [ __ ]
is so
superhuman and so heroic he puts aside
the grudge he could
and [ __ ] rightfully should have
against the person responsible for up
you know overturning his entire life or
at least giving the information
to somebody who got that information to
kingpin and instead
he holds her in this [ __ ] embrace and
she's bawling her eyes out it's one of
my favorite [ __ ] comic book panels of
all time and it's a splash page
because it says everything about
superheroism that you don't really see
we always enjoy the story where
[ __ ] punches another part
and stands over him and like i've
delivered justice
what is more beautiful and pure and just
than that somebody who is so committed
to the cause of justice that they can
step above their own
personal perhaps reproach
and [ __ ] forgive and it happened in a
book with a character that is very
catholic
oriented as daredevil is so as a
catholic kid that like hit me so hard it
still hits me to this day
mark over to you again
one of those like i gotta follow the
rolling stones now
great um i similarly have two
two ideas the first is an issue of the
sandman
which i read the sandman you know as it
was coming out
i bought it you know monthly but i
didn't know what i wanted to be when i
grew up
you know like i was i was in that phase
of like you know i was
like just out of college just starting
to work
um i was an editor at a magazine called
starlog but i didn't know if
that's what i wanted i loved comic books
my entire life but like
who am i going to be and sandman is a
book
um that is a lot of things but it's also
a book about
story and about who gets to tell stories
and about how the you build a framework
for those stories
and so there's an issue that's issue 19
um called midsummer night's dream
where william shakespeare is taking his
company of players out into the middle
of the wood
um and they don't know why they're going
out there and he's written the play and
they're going to perform it and who's
our audience going to be and then some
giant door opens up in the side of like
fiddler's green
and out walks the entire like fairy host
to come and watch the performance of
midsummer night's dream
and there's this moment where lord
oberon turns to
to morpheus and uh and is complimenting
william shakespeare on having for the
first time
gotten their likenesses right like he
knows who we are it's like well i told
him everything i knew about you and so
he's the first one who got us right
and so that feeling the the
responsibility
of telling stories and respecting the
people you're telling stories about
and doing the work to make sure those
stories feel good to the people who are
ingesting them
you know sandman made me want to be a
writer
but that story made me want to write the
kind of stories that i tell
which are about specific people and
their worlds and
sometimes you don't see those worlds a
lot but the the importance of making
sure that those worlds and those people
and
those characters are portrayed with as
much regular as i can
um i sort of got in a back ass you know
sort of way from from sandman nice
um remember that issue beautiful yeah i
mean it's gorgeous
um and then the other one is you know
it's a thing that i continue
to try and process and will do so for
the rest of my life
but um i've got an autistic kid
and and growing up you know i didn't
know any people who are autistic or at
the very least
you know it wasn't a thing we talked
about back in the 70s and 80s like that
gets special
or different or you know god forbid a
[ __ ]
um which is a word we'd no longer use
for plenty of reasons all of them valid
but then when i had an autistic kid like
processing
the feelings about it and my my own
perspective on it
you know i ultimately processed all
those feelings by writing a comic book
about a kid with autism
um and so it's still and it's a work in
progress
my own feelings about it but at the very
least i was able to synthesize some of
those feelings and
and hopes and dreams and wants and and
failures and disasters and heartbreaks
into into this comic book called adora
in the distance which
i don't mean to plug my work right now
because
that's not what i'm here for but the
idea of
comic books helping you to process
events in your life
i think that's a very big part of what
art does for people who make art
which is here's what i am at the moment
that i am and here's how i'm trying to
understand
where who i am and when i am and being
able to
have that kind of pillar in the sand
and because your life is always shifting
under you but that thing exists
as a moment in time where you were that
guy and that's what you felt about that
thing
and so for me that's what adore is it's
the the person that i was when i
discovered that i had an autistic child
and how i tried to understand who she
was when she couldn't tell me
and so that's what that book is and
that's what that book does for me
beautiful [ __ ] answer give it up for
mark ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
i um i saw it was this week that the
hollywood reporter
wrote something about you i saw like the
headline was the
author or writer searches for his
daughter inside a comic book was that
this week
it was this week it was vanity fair
vanity [ __ ] fair
man yeah who did you blow
that's a major ink man i was happy when
i thought it was thr
jesus man that's [ __ ] great how was
the piece i just read the headline
yeah no it was it was a very very warm
piece it was written by anthony
bresnikin who you may or may not have
any like interplay with but
i mean i love that dude i've worked with
him when we were at ew together
um but i have never been on this end of
his
scalpel you know as a patient as a
subject of an interview
and it was it was a fantastic experience
because
i'm talking about stuff that's really
really personal and and things that are
um really close to my heart so he was he
was very gentle with me
um which is what you'd expect from a
tender lover
and who i completely believe anthony
bresnik is so that's how he got the
story in vanity fair
you were not making it up
for our questioner thank you sir
thank you um all right bam man get in
here and feed us from the internet man
so you don't get slaughtered
back all right um this
uh this question is from elise deals
and they would like to know uh
you need a group therapy session which
superheroes would you want in your group
that's really good um i've never i've
never done
therapy or group therapy i mean i would
actually i'm lying i did go to therapy
once and i was like i don't think i
need this um and not because i'm like
i'm better than people but i'm like
i have podcasts and so i just went and
told my problems there but
um i've never been in group therapy so
is the idea of group therapy
like uh rick and morty where the family
goes together to group therapy
so it's that kind of thing what family
members would i want you or who do i
want in my group therapy
like is the idea you're supposed to
learn from others in group therapy
bamf uh i've never done group therapy
either
but i imagine it could also be like an
aaa
type meeting you know like thank you
that well done now i can translate that
and [ __ ] so i'm like all right what
other
comic book characters are like me and
who do i want to be in a [ __ ] group
with black bolt
from the inhumans
lots of silent peoples you can have the
story from the teen titans
you're catching on to the bit aren't you
i see it happening
uh who else does uh no i was gonna say
grodd but all he does is talk
um groot groot
excellent [ __ ] call he'd be the
leader of the group because he at least
says something
could you go a little deeper i am groot
could do no but more can you reveal i am
groot
you're not helping her i am rude um and
of course since i love him and
everything batman
because if you're batman and group
therapy you're gonna hear interesting
[ __ ] every [ __ ] week
you know sometimes i imagine you guys
sit there listening to problems of
others you know i gotta give a [ __ ]
rat's
ass about this stranger but if somebody
was just like my [ __ ]
little boy i hang out with got shot by a
question mark
you'd be like you're the most
fascinating person in this room
who do go on what about you mark
uh yeah i mean batman was first on my
list because
that motherfucker's got issues yes
um ben grimm i feel like would be
interesting
um because there's a guy who's always
like you know keeping the sunny side up
but you know
he's just like i'm made of orange rock
he'd want to let loose in the room it's
not even cool rock it's [ __ ]
orange there are no real orange rocks in
life
i can't blend in anywhere the youtube
geologists be like you [ __ ] idiot
there are such things as orange rocks
i'm sure there are my bad
um let's see i mean daredevil
clearly that's another dude who's got
lots of [ __ ] to process
yeah but that's like catholic [ __ ] you
don't wanna [ __ ] with that man
you know one piece of that yeah that's
tough because that's wrapped up in god
and then you gotta get into the god
thing with him and stuff and
you know that dude's had some issues
plus it's like a nun
yeah actually he'd be fairly fascinating
on that level as well
um speaking of of aaa you know tony
stark
also like classic narcissist also
substance abuse issues like that's a
dude who's got some stories to tell
way more entertaining than [ __ ]
batman as well
yeah but batman and tony stark in the
same [ __ ] group therapy
like that would just be fun they would
[ __ ] hate each other
oh my god that's it i think we've
narrowed our group down
bruce wayne and the rest of us just
going like this
oh bam man's in you should throw in
uh charles xavier so that when tony and
batman were lying he could be like
you're lying
you're exaggerating you don't have that
much money
that's true we'd find out who the real
[ __ ] billionaire is man
um excellent job what a great question
who said that on the internet
who was the questioner uh that was elise
deals
well done elise dean give it up for
elite deals everybody
um oh my god can you believe it we've
done it we've gotten to the end of the
show were there any technical
difficulties the entire time
jc banff man bamf um
the same uh eight people in chat
complained about the audio that complain
about it every week but outside of that
no we're fine
it's not bad but they complain about the
audio the same way they do every week
right yeah
consistent anybody here um what does
anybody talk about the camera work i
thought josh is doing a nice job in the
back of the room
he's shooting long lens and [ __ ] um
no
come on bro your producer can't you just
like sweet talk maybe like oh that's all
they talked about and [ __ ]
um i think people were excited that it
was like this weird hybrid of a show
that's just from the back it goes jc is
a prick
all right good to know man uh but more
importantly [ __ ] the internet because we
can't see or hear them for all we know
they don't exist
these people are real did you have a
good time tonight ladies and gentlemen
i see applause thank you enough for
coming out here to smod castle on the
second
night ever uh for this hybrid of fat man
uh beyond show like i said the second
half of august
feels like mark's going to be out here
so we'll be able to do it uh together
here in the room uh thank you to jc
for hooking it up give it up for banff
man himself jason
uh if you're in california or in
hollywood or you're not get to hollywood
california and go to the scum and
villainy cantina open up right now do
you have to did they reinstate masks
jc no masks
yet because new sims getting recalled so
they there are governors being recalled
so he's doing everything he can to not
uh not rock the boat oh is that right so
even though the scientist is like we
should remask he's like no i want to get
reelected
yeah basically people for a second kid
um uh here at the wawa west man no mask
whatsoever and [ __ ] everything is legal
in new jersey
they were just like we don't have
anything to say to them um
thank you jc for making it happen but
ladies and gentlemen there is no show
without the guy that normally uh sits
beside me but it today
sits in that little box you see on your
screen give it up for uh the great
mark bernard and ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
thank you sir
um we are going to head into our late
night
uh smog castle show tonight which is a
screening of a movie you can't say what
is special screening and stuff
uh so we've been running a little late
so we're gonna uh
rush out of here ladies and gentlemen
but thank you for spending all the time
with us here uh at home
uh thank you to the audience for
spending time with us here in person
we've been talking about doing this for
months and you know we kind of pulled it
they pulled it together uh today and it
turned out kind of well so it looks like
we
might be able to continue doing this
like all the summer long on the weekends
game mark let's give it a go my friend
yo
man that ladies and gentlemen is fat man
beyond for this week i'm kevin smith
i'm mark bernard tune in next time same
that time same fat channel smodcast.com
or
youtube.com kevin smith jeff's kiss
everybody give it up folks
you